“SCP-682 must be destroyed as soon as possible.”
So begins the SCP Foundation file on the dreaded
SCP - 682, a highly-intelligent reptilian
monster that has - despite the Foundation’s
best efforts - proved impossible to kill.
It may not be the most dangerous SCP out there,
considering that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities, but it’s one of the most
iconic, and you’ve probably heard tales
of the monster that death forgot, and you
know exactly why everyone is so afraid of
the so-called “Hard to Kill Reptile”.
It’s been subjected to some of the most
deadly weapons and traps the Foundation could
devise, and survived attacks from some of
its deadliest fellow SCPs.
But before we tell you about the Foundation’s
many failed assassination attempts against
the so-called “Hard to Kill Reptile”,
we need a little more groundwork on what this
creature even is.
The first thing to know about SCP - 682, is
that this thing wants you and everyone you
know dead.
Unlike some other creatures like SCP - 096
and SCP - 173, which are murderous but exhibit
no real higher processing skills, SCP - 682
possesses cunning, advanced reasoning, and
even human-level logical intelligence.
SCP - 682 can engage you in conversation,
but just talking to the creature calmly and
cordially will sometimes cause it to enter
its “rage state” where it becomes even
more dangerous and volatile.
The beast is perpetually kept in a huge tank
of powerful hydrochloric acid, melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its full
potential and going on a rampage.
The creature’s most terrifying asset, and
the reason it’s proven impossible to terminate
thus far, is its incredible adaptability to
any and all external stimuli.
682 is a reactive being, capable of not only
surviving and regenerating from all attacks,
but often incorporating those attacks into
its own wide arsenal.
In other words, if you’re hoping to kill
this thing, you better kill it on the first
hit - cause if you don’t, you better believe
it’s gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder.
This brings us to the main event: Some of
the SCP Foundation’s most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate SCP - 682,
or even understand how it could theoretically
be terminated.
There are quite literally too many unsuccessful
attempts for us to list them all here, so
think of this as a highlight
reel of the Foundation’s
most prominent failures.
682 was first cross-tested with SCP - 017,
a humanoid shadow-entity shown to be able
to consume matter with its shadows and leave
no traces behind.
Tests on tissue samples from 682 showed that
SCP - 017 was able to consume said tissues
with no adverse effects.
However, when SCP - 017 was placed into the
containment chamber with the actual creature,
682 let out a horrific roar that was so loud
it damaged nearby audio equipment.
SCP - 017 fled to the corner of the room,
and 682, in its rage state, attempted to breach
containment.
Agents managed to suppress and remove the
creature, but no meaningful damage was logged.
Attempt failed.
SCP - 173 - the Killer statue - was later
brought in, hoping that its thus-far impeccable
track recording for killing would hold strong.
The second that 173 was introduced into the
testing area, 682 retreated to the far wall
and began screeching intensely.
It was intelligent enough to know what it
was dealing with here.
While the researchers and guards expected
an instantaneous reaction, there was actually
a stalemate for over six hours as 682 stared
at 173 continuously.
Eventually, the tie was broken when Agents
shot out 682’s eyes with high-caliber sniper
rifles, breaking the line of sight and causing
173 to attack.
Though 682 sustained damage to several parts
of its body while its eyes regenerated, the
creature was not killed.
It then regenerated a number of eyes all over
its body, covered in a clear, armoured carapace
that made them resistant to bullets.
The stalemate continued for an additional
twelve hours, as 682 maintained perpetual
eye contact.
173 was eventually removed from the containment
unit, and the mission was aborted.
Attempt failed.
In their desperation, the SCP Foundation resorted
to bringing in another dangerous and seemingly
unkillable monster to take on 682: SCP - 096,
also known as The Shy Guy.
As astute SCP fans will already know, this
being kills anything that sees its face, with
no known exceptions - and when it enters its
attack mode, it’s thought to be quite literally
unstoppable.
Or, at least, it was.
While SCP - 096 was able to destroy 85% of
682’s original body mass during their 27
hour battle, it was left
mentally broken - wounded,
and huddled in the corner.
To this day, if ever confronted with SCP 682,
the Shy Guy reacts in pure terror, turning
away and clawing at his own face.
Attempt failed.
During a deadly containment breach, SCP - 682
also went head to head organically with another
iconic SCP hall-of-famer: SCP - 106, also
known as The Old Man.
The Old Man and a shapeshifting, psionic anomaly
known as SCP - 953 broke into 682’s containment
cell.
The Old Man pulled both of his fellow anomalous
combatants into his pocket dimension to continue
the battle on his terms.
However, despite losing 67% of his body mass
during the ensuing pocket dimension showdown,
682 still prevailed - with the Old Man eventually
fleeing back to his cell, and 953 being collected
and taken away by agents.
Once again, SCP - 682 continued to hold the
title.
But it wasn’t just cross-testing experiments,
intentional or otherwise.
The SCP Foundation’s quest to kill 682 lead
them to a number of more conventional murder
methods, all with varying degrees of success.
Due to SCP - 682’s highly adaptive abilities,
some methods were discounted from the outset.
For example, launching a powerful thermonuclear
missile at the creature was soundly rejected
by O5 Command - on the premise that, if the
creature wasn’t destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes,
humanity would be pretty much done for.
Other ideas were abandoned just for being
too ridiculous - such as one researcher’s
suggestion to fly the creature through the
air and drop it from a considerable height,
hoping to kill it with the high-altitude impact.
I’m not sure we even need to tell you why
that’s a terrible idea.
But, during the experiments on SCP - 682,
the studies ranged from honest to incompetent
to straight-up evil.
One guest researcher fed two small, innocent
children to the creature, just to see what
would happen.
He was then himself fed to the creature for
his sadistic behaviour, which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional conduct.
After all, the Foundation is meant to be cold,
not cruel.
It was SCP - 682 that had the monopoly on
cruelty.
Memetic Kill agents were a resounding failure.
They attempted to dismember 682 with a powerful
laser, only to have the
creature develop reflective
surfaces that displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around it.
They attempted to kill the creature by sucking
all the air out of its containment facility
and creating a vacuum, but it expelled a dangerous
gaseous compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again introduced
into the room.
The Foundation used high-precision blades
to slice SCP - 682 into approximately 12,000
pieces then separated these pieces.
Unsurprisingly by this point, this attempt
also failed.
The 12,000 pieces reformed a short while later
into the fully operational killing machine
we all know and fear.
In one particularly frightening display of
intelligence and adaptability, the Foundation
attempted to kill 682 with extreme heat, but
it shielded itself by developing a secondary
carapace composed of solid helium.
When personnel entered the room following
the failed attempt on the creature’s life,
it shattered its helium carapace into deadly
shards that fired around the room and shredded
all Foundation personnel in attendance.
It’d set a trap, and that trap had been
wildly successful.
The creature’s ability to adapt to seemingly
any offensive is unparalleled, to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how to
classify this creature - whether it’s organic,
inorganic, or even alive at all based on any
definitions we could understand.
At every turn, the creature just raised more
questions.
What is it?
Is it possible to destroy it at all by any
means?
Who was even trying to kill who here?
Because it certainly seemed like SCP - 682
had a masterful K/D ratio by now.
More extreme feats of cross-testing continued
in the Foundation’s growing desperation
to eliminate this monster.
SCP - 162, which is a hypnotic ball of sharp
objects, hooks, and high-tension fishing line,
was introduced to 682’s containment cell.
The hooks latched onto the creature and tore
huge portions off, including its entire lower
jaw and one of its limbs.
However, 682 was still able to breach containment,
kill eleven people, and badly wound 86 others.
It regenerated its severe injuries in no time.
The beast was even taken to the domain of
The Gate Guardian, one of the proposals for
SCP - 001.
The Guardian has a flaming sword hotter than
the sun, capable of destroying its targets
on an atomic level.
Naturally, SCP - 682 survived and regenerated.
Perhaps the most fascinating cross-test of
all was between 682 and SCP - 053, who manifests
as a kind, innocent little
girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal tendencies
in all who come into contact with her for
more than ten minutes.
The people with these tendencies would then
attempt to harm the girl, but would immediately
drop dead shortly after, leaving the girl
intact.
The researchers present anticipated two possible
outcomes here: The optimistic outcome, in
which 682 entered a rage state, attacked 053,
and died for good.
And the realistic outcome, in which 682 attacked
053, possibly experienced some minor injury
or nothing at all, and 053 had to be removed
from the containment cell.
But that didn’t happen.
What did occur was considerably more shocking
than any kind of violence.
When 053 entered 682’s containment chamber,
the monster became uncharacteristically docile.
Researchers and staff were baffled, and watched
with amazement as 053 approached the terrifying,
immortal, mass-murdering monster...and began
to play with it.
682 even allowed 053 to draw on its face with
crayons.
Researchers thought they must’ve been dreaming,
seeing this surreal display play out.
053 even appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope.
It was a single act in defiance of everything
they thought they knew.
When Foundation personnel entered the containment
cell to separate the two, 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards.
053 also wept, sad at being separated from
her new friend.
To this day, despite further testing, the
Foundation has no idea how or why this happened.
Like many details surrounding SCP - 682, it’s
shrouded in deeply frustrating mystery.
And so the tale of SCP - 682 continues, in
spite of the Foundation’s best efforts.
The monster continues to breach containment
and slaughter with some regularity, taking
out its seemingly limitless hatred for not
only human beings, but anything that dares
draw breath.
Nobody knows where exactly the creature is
from, what its true nature is, or why its
ability to adapt and regenerate far exceeds
any known organism on this planet.
Perhaps one day, through enough research and
cross testing, we can someday answer these
questions with scientific precision, but until
then, we only have one answer: Hatred never
dies.
Here we go again. It’s time to return to the
acid-filled containment chamber of SCP-682,
more commonly known as the Hard to Destroy
Reptile. We’ve spoken about him and the ways
The SCP Foundation has attempted to destroy him
in a previous video. But as we said back then,
we really only scratched the surface
of the huge number of insane ways
the Foundation has tried to wipe this
ornery lizard off the face of the earth.
Today, we’re filling in some of the cracks.
Let’s take a look at the secret test logs
detailing the Foundation’s unsuccessful
quest to finally destroy SCP-682. If you’re
a real SCP Expert, you’re likely to recognize
some familiar faces we meet along the way...
Esteemed Foundation Researcher Dr. Alto
Clef - famed for his somewhat unconventional
personality - entered the test chamber to see
if he could intimidate the beast to death. This
resulted in a long staring contest between
Dr. Clef and 682, towards the end of which,
Dr. Clef began to lose his nerve. He
tried to leave the room, only to find
that the door was locked, causing him to swear
loudly. Dr. Clef, who always tries to find the
most direct solution to his problems, blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran off.
Test failed.
Next came SCP-662, a silver
hand bell that summons the supernaturally helpful
butler, Mr. Deeds. When Mr. Deeds was summoned,
Foundation researchers asked him if he could kill
SCP-682. Deeds politely explained that he wouldn’t
be capable of killing 682, it’s just too strong.
When asked if he could at least incapacitate 682,
he replied that the best way to do this would
be to poison himself and allow 682 to eat his
body. But this, he reminded, would only
be a temporary problem for the lizard.
Test failed.
The Foundation brought in SCP-689,
a terrifying soapstone statue of a sitting
skeleton that can kill you if you see it and
then stop paying attention to it. 682 first
observed the statue, and then the Foundation
turned off the lights. When they turned them
back on, SCP-682 appeared to be dead in a
puddle of gray and black liquid. D-Classes were
sent in to confirm that 682 was actually dead,
but it instead got up and killed them. Researchers
theorized that 682’s definition of “life” is
not quite the same as ours, rendering
689’s death-related powers ineffective.
Test failed.
SCP-807 was next up to bat. This is
an anomalous salmon-colored ceramic
dinner plate with the words "Last Chance
Diner" printed on the edges in white. Any
food placed on it becomes irresistible by any
definition, but when the food is consumed it
causes immediate cardiac arrest due to the
sudden clogging of the arteries with fat.
Researchers made a meal known as the
“682 Special” - 10 kg of rotten meat
and sharpened bone splinters, 10 L of
rancid mayonnaise, 1 L potassium cyanide,
and 1 kg morphine hydrochloride,
combined into a solid mass and
transmuted by 807. When 682 first consumed
this disgusting meal, it seemed to collapse.
However, when D-Classes were sent in to see
whether 682 was truly out for the count,
multiple holes opened in its body. These
holes fired out high-pressure jets of blood,
killing the nearby D-Classes and destroying
the containment cell. 682 was fine afterwards.
Test failed.
To kill 682,
it seemed that the Foundation really needed
to have God on their side. So they tried to
recruit SCP-343, also known as “God”, to
help them destroy the beast. However, when
he entered the containment chamber, he somehow
couldn’t even see the beast. When researchers
asked him whether he could kill 682, God replied,
“He's not one of mine. Deal with him yourself."
Test failed.
Next, the Foundation recruited SCP-524: A small
white rabbit that can eat literally anything,
including itself, without being harmed. The
rabbit was released into SCP-682’s chamber,
at which point it approached 682 and began to
eat one of its legs. 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall, out of 524’s reach, where
it remained for a number of hours. At this point,
SCP-524 seemed to become bored, and began eating
its way out of containment through a nearby wall.
Test failed.
Maybe the luck of the Irish was what the
Foundation needed to finally put this
monster to rest. They recruited SCP-1933, a
fat man dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are entirely the alcoholic beverage known
as Irish Cream. However, if enough of this Irish
cream is fed to something, all of their bodily
fluids will become Irish cream, killing them.
The Foundation fed large quantities of this
Irish cream to SCP-682. At first, it appeared
intoxicated, a promising sign. However, it vomited
out a massive quantity of SCP-1933 bodily fluids,
turning the walls of its cell into Irish cream
and allowing it to escape and wreak havoc.
Test failed.
The Foundation recruited the help of SCP-2337,
an intelligent corn crake known as Dr. Spanko,
with a voice so loud it can quite literally
talk its victims to death if it speaks to them
for an extended period of time. It was sent
into SCP-682’s chamber to destroy the beast,
but 682 just told it to leave, and the
talkative bird obliged - by blowing
away one of the chamber walls with a yell,
allowing SCP-682 to breach containment again.
Test failed.
As you can probably sympathize with right now,
the Foundation researchers were starting to get
a little frustrated with their lack of progress.
They even pitched the possibility of sending
SCP-682 into an alternate dimension, perhaps
into a stalemate against its alternate self.
But this pitch was shot down by the O5 Council on
the grounds that it was way, way, way too risky.
Back to the drawing board. By which
we mean, they literally transformed
SCP-682’s skin into a kind of drawing board.
SCP-2521 is an anomaly that manifests any
time information about it is recorded, and
immediately grabs the source of the information,
wrapping it in its tendrils and taking it
away with it. The Foundation sought to take
advantage of this by using a laser to cut
this anomalous information into SCP-682’s
side. However, this didn’t have the
results that they were hoping for.
SCP-2521 did turn up to take the
information, but it only took the
skin on which the information was carved.
682 survived and quickly grew back its skin.
Test failed.
Researchers suggested tracking down SCP-169,
an obscenely massive underwater creature known
as The Leviathan, and feeding 682 to the beast.
However, this idea was immediately shot down
by the O5 Council. If 682 did what it did best:
Surviving the attack and acting accordingly,
perhaps by growing to the size of SCP-169,
it would likely trigger an XK-Class End of the
World Scenario. It simply was not worth the risk.
The Foundation released two specimens of SCP-939
into 682’s test chamber. These voice-imitating,
amnesia-inducing monsters have
caused huge damage to human targets,
so maybe they had some hope against 682.
This hope turned out to be misplaced:
Both specimens seemed extremely distressed by
682’s presence and refused to engage. 682 did not
have that same refusal. It charged in and brutally
killed both, before devouring their corpses.
Test failed.
In a very well-documented case, the adorable
SCP-999 was introduced into 682’s test chamber.
The unassailable good vibes provided by 999,
as well as an intense tickle fight, did actually
lead to the temporary incapacitation of SCP-682.
However, the otherwise wholesome incident ended in
tragedy when 682 adapted to the good vibes and was
able to release a kind of violent laughter
wave. This incapacitated much of the staff
and allowed 682 to breach containment and go on
another killing spree, before being recontained.
Test, once again, failed.
One of the closest attempts the
Foundation ever had involved SCP-294,
an anomalous coffee machine that can
produce any liquid typed into its keypad.
Foundation researchers requested “SCP-682
Killer” from the machine, and were astounded
at the results. During tests on SCP-682 tissue
samples, the liquid was capable of causing 682
tissue to decay and crumble. Tests on the living
creature were similarly promising. The acid in
682’s tank was receded, and one liter of SCP-682
Killer was poured onto it, causing that portion
of its flesh to immediately decay. When the acid
was returned, this portion dissolved instantly.
Scientists believe that if they could one day
get a large enough quantity of this liquid,
they might have a viable option.
But until then, the tests march on.
They introduced SCP-055, the self-keeping
secret, into the containment chamber of
SCP-682. We don’t really know what happened,
but seeing as 682 isn’t dead, we now know that
055 can’t kill it. That and the fact it isn’t
round is pretty much all we know about SCP-055.
Test failed.
Next came SCP-082, also known as Fernand the
Cannibal. Fernand was first presented a piece
of flesh from 682, but rather than eating
it, he inspected it and began to express
joy that his “friend” still lived. When
introduced into 682’s testing chamber,
Fernand attempted to subdue the lizard
and use it as his steed. 682 expressed
an intense hatred of both Fernand and the
idea of being Fernand’s steed, so the two of
them engaged in combat. Mobile Task Forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both subjects.
In the debrief interview, both hinted
that the two of them shared history
prior to containment. 682 was
reluctant to talk about it.
Test failed.
Researchers were becoming extremely frustrated
with SCP-682’s unwillingness to die,
so they called in an SCP who responded
to reason much better: SCP-049,
the Plague Doctor. This sinister surgeon can
kill with a touch, and the Foundation hoped
that would extend to 682. However, the result
was a dud. The Plague Doctor did touch 682,
but it experienced no adverse effects, and
even swiped at the doctor. Upon leaving,
049 reported feeling “emotionally
disturbed” by his encounter with SCP-682.
Yep, you guessed it: Test failed.
If it gives you any indication of just how
desperate the researchers were at this point,
Dr. Richard Graham pondered whether introducing
SCP-682 to a human with just as pessimistic and
misanthropic feelings as itself would somehow
pacify it. They sent in a particularly nasty
D-Class, and the two spoke. Fascinatingly,
682 didn’t attempt to harm this D-Class,
they just shared their profane and bleak
sentiments about the human race with one another.
However, some of 682’s opinions were a
little too spicy for this D-Class. After
listening to the reptile speak for twenty
minutes, the D-Class fell into a catatonic
state from the sheer depression
of it all. He died not long after.
One anonymous researcher suggested perhaps the
worst idea of all: Letting SCP-682 out into the
wild. Not even to really terminate it, just
to see what it does. The anonymous scientist
figured there would be some merit in
analyzing the creature’s behavior.
As you can probably guess, this
request was shot down by the O5
Council. The note attached to the request
by one of its members summed it up best:
“I'll tell you what it'll do. It'll go out for
a nice stroll, murder a few innocent people,
go fishing, slaughter a few more innocent people,
start up a tech-company, eat a few more innocent
people, go on a vacation to Florida, dismember a
few more innocent people! I swear, when I find out
who wrote this, you can personally enter 682's
containment chamber to analyze him yourself!”
Even this isn’t covering every
single attempt to terminate SCP-682,
but all attempts have either been failures or too
risky or potentially unviable to even try. Sadly,
for the SCP Foundation and the human race, it’s
likely we’ll be dealing with SCP-682 for a long
time to come. How do you think 682 could finally
be killed? Let us know down in the comments below!
SCP-682.
Does it even require an introduction?
The SCP Foundation thinks this cantankerous
reptile needs a serious attitude adjustment
- By which we mean, they really, really want
to kill it.
But as you might have seen in our previous
videos on the subject, they don’t call this
monstrosity the “Hard to Destroy Reptile”
for nothing.
That’s why we’ve done what the Foundation
isn’t allowed to - we outsourced the dirty
job of squashing this lizard to all of you!
We made a community post asking for your ideas
on how this scaly abomination can finally
be destroyed, and you delivered big time!
A truly staggering amount with over 6,000
comments!
Now let’s see if we can finally get our
answer, because believe us, the Foundation
is desperate at this point.
Idk what to write for a name said, “The
most effective way that Dr Bright approves
of: CHAINSAW CANNON.”
As awesome as a chainsaw cannon would probably
be to use, it sadly wouldn’t be very effective
against SCP-682.
Chainsaws are blades, and we know from the
termination test logs that blades have been
ineffective.
Even when SCP-682 is chopped up into tiny
little pieces, those pieces have a nasty habit
of reforming into the big, ugly monster we
all know and fear.
AwesomeCardinal said, “The SCP Foundation
could try to bring it to the void in Russia
where the Pattern Screamers are.”
This was a popular idea and the Foundation
actually tried this.
The SCP being referred to here is SCP-3930,
a big ol’ pile of nothing in Russia that
causes things inside it to stop existing.
When they threw SCP-682 inside, it technically
did stop existing.
Despite this, it could still be perceived,
and still caused the deaths of all surrounding
researchers.
Fifteen hours later, it just reappeared in
its containment chamber, apparently totally
fine.
You can probably see why the Foundation is
frustrated by this thing.
Sc0r3cr0w and Friends said, “Black hole.
Need I say more?”
You may need to say a little more.
For starters, there would be logistical issues
in actually getting the creature anywhere
near a black hole.
But there’s also the concern that it may
just adapt its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole.
Or, even scarier, somehow adapts to reproduce
the powers of a black hole.
It probably wouldn’t be worth the risk of
ending up with a reptile capable of creating
gamma ray bursts.
StellarSolar Sky said, “Put the reptile
inside nuclear fusion and watch its particles
disappear.”
The Foundation tried something pretty close
to this, by trying to put it inside SCP-536
- A chamber where they can use dials to control
the physical constants within.
They increased the speed of light and nuclear
force within the chamber, which caused SCP-682
to disintegrate until all that was left was
a piece of matter 1% of its original size.
However, the creature then reformed and killed
the researchers.
Later tests showed that its body had become
an unknown form of matter, held together by
quantum effects impossible to unravel with
our current understanding of science.
Bray of fun said, “So you know that coffee
machine thing that is 294?
Type in "682 killing substance" and repeat
that until you have enough to fill its entire
room, then fill it.”
They did actually try this, and the resulting
substance was effective in damaging SCP-682’s
tissue.
However, the one problem is that it’s extremely
difficult to produce enough of this stuff
to actually submerge the creature.
Worse still, if enough of it was made to cause
significant damage to the body of SCP-682,
it may adapt to the chemical as a defense
mechanism, making it ineffective as a weapon.
Its adaptive ability is truly SCP-682’s
greatest asset when it comes to thwarting
the Foundation’s constant attempts to kill
it.
Alex Webb said, “Ask it kindly to die.”
We don’t believe that the Foundation has
ever actually tried this one, but just based
on the fact that SCP-682 is a huge jerk on
top of being an omnicidal monster, he probably
wouldn’t respond to polite requests.
iFlashboy said, “I wonder if Doom Slayer
could defeat the reptile.
He’s torn through every demon in hell, and
even titans, so would 682 be a challenge or
just another Tuesday for the slayer?”
That’s a slightly trickier one.
Of course, since they exist
in different universes,
we’ll never see an official battle between
the Doom Slayer and SCP-682.
However, given that the Doom Slayer’s weapons
are all conventional - meaning, largely based
around slashing, crushing, shooting, and blasting
- we don’t know whether he’d actually
be able to slay the beast.
That being said, we don’t know if 682 could
kill him, either.
We could have a stalemate on our hands here...
Amanda Breneman said, “I asked my sister
(who’s never heard of SCP’s) this question,
and her answer was “You hit it again”.”
Amanda, your sister may be the one to finally
stop this creature.
Getting the two of them in the same room may
be the biggest logistical problem here.
Samuel Pascual said, “Throwing him down
SCP-087, so he suffers and is contained once
and for all in the improbable case he is still
alive.”
SCP-087 - the Endless Staircase - can be a
dangerous anomaly for humans who don’t know
what they’re getting into.
However, SCP-682 would likely detect the threat
far earlier than any human, and then breach
containment.
It’s definitely gotten out of stickier situations.
Yashasheree Charya said, “Send him to endless
IKEA where he will be trapped forever.”
Much like SCP-087, the Endless Ikea wouldn’t
pose the same threat to SCP-682 as it would
for the average human trapped inside.
The staff would be no trouble for 682, and
it would be able to devote pretty much all
of its time in there to finding a way out.
And when he did finally break out, he’d
probably be armed with the terrifying knowledge
of how to correctly assemble a svendendorkk.
We shudder at the thought.
Jack Lost said, “Oxygen Destroyer.
Used to deal with another big lizard issue
back in 1954.”
Sadly, this would also likely be an ineffective
weapon against SCP-682, because the creature
thrives in anaerobic environments - seeing
as its native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen, and according to Foundation tests,
it can survive just fine in a vacuum.
Whether SCP-682 could take Godzilla in a fight
is still up for debate and you can argue about
which lizard would reign supreme in the comments.
Ace Godwin said, “Just don’t kill him,
let him live, bro, he hasn't done anything
wrong yet.
Let him vibe in his chamber.”
Wait a second…
Did SCP-682 write this?
Moving on.
A lot of you said, “Throw him into the sun.”
While the sun is a gigantic nuclear furnace
where hydrogen is built
into helium at a temperature
of millions of degrees, there is the the issue
of it not only being beyond
difficult to incapacitate
the creature for long enough to get it into
the rocket, but also the problem of the sun
being 93 millions miles away from earth.
It’s a long trip there no matter what, and
during that time, SCP-682 would almost definitely
figure out a way to return to earth.
It might even rewire the rocket and turn it
into its own personal vehicle, giving it the
freedom to cause chaos around the solar system.
And even if everything else went well, SCP-682
would still probably survive being thrown
into the sun.
After all, The Gate Guardian’s flaming sword
is described as being hotter than the sun,
and it didn’t manage to kill the hard-to-destroy
reptile.
PokemonRedBoy said, “Send him to Mars and
launch a nuke that can destroy a planet along
with the SCP.”
While a nuke capable of destroying the planet
Mars would also likely destroy SCP-682 in
the process, the destruction of Mars itself
would likely cause such a catastrophic shift
in our neck of the solar system that we’d
probably die with it.
The question, at that point, is whether it’s
really worth killing ourselves to take down
the lizard?
Artemis said, “Let it live with 999 its
entire life and it's not a threat.”
This is a double-edged sword.
During their cross-test, SCP-999 did pacify
SCP-682 and put it in a state of bliss and
laughter for a brief period.
However, this actually resulted in a pretty
catastrophic tragedy, too.
682 adapted to 999’s effects and released
a beam of laughter that incapacitated everyone
around it, allowing it to escape and go on
a killing spree.
So maybe the two are better kept apart...
Dr. wasup said, “I'd give 682 a jar of pickles
to open, and the jar would be so tight that
682 couldn't open it and
he would be so embarrassed
by it that he would just destroy himself.”
You may actually be on to something here.
We know we’d be extremely embarrassed if
we couldn’t open the jar.
But there are three major problems.
One, where does one get such a jar?
Can SCP-343 make a jar of pickles so difficult
to open that even he himself can’t open
it?
Two, we don’t know if SCP-682 likes pickles
enough to make opening the jar an attractive
prospect.
And three, if it does turn out it likes pickles,
it would probably just eat the jar too.
Shuvro Bhattacharjee said, “To deal with
him in my opinion, send SCP-682 into SCP-3001,
aka the Red Reality.
That's my theory.”
This could potentially be an effective method
of trapping SCP-682 for a period of time.
However, the problem is that there’s no
reliable way to access the Red Reality.
The only person who’s ever really been inside
is Robert Scranton, and he ended up there
completely by accident.
So this doesn’t seem to be
a reliable neutralization
method for SCP-682.
Adding to that, the panel that Dr. Scranton
was transported to the Red Reality with eventually
came back, which means it might only be a
temporary solution anyway.
MistakeToSociaty Yay said, “Can someone
ride SCP-682 without them dying?”
This isn’t technically about neutralizing
SCP-682, but it deserves an answer.
While it appears that some people are able
to ride 682 such as SCP-053, the Little Girl
and 05-6 aka The American in the Ouroboros
cycle, he doesn’t seem to enjoy it.
At least he didn’t when SCP-082, better
known as Fernand the Cannibal attempted it.
Of course Fernand describes their relationship
quite differently, insisting that 682 is his
Bayard… his magical steed.
Laura Garcia said, “Chop it up, put the
pieces in a giant bowl with egg beaters stirring
it constantly so it can't reanimate.
Keep it kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform.
Giant Egg Beating Machine to prevent Reformation.
Killing it would take a Rigel sun blast to
stop it from reanimating itself.”
This has got to be one of the most creative
ones we’ve encountered.
Even Dr. Bright probably wouldn’t think
to use giant whisks on the beast.
However, it probably wouldn’t kill the ornery
creature for good.
As we’ve said before, not only has the beast
regenerated from things as hot as the sun,
he’s also able to remanifest from the tiniest
atoms, or even nothing at all.
On the plus side, he may reanimate with a
new super whisking ability, and could potentially
give SCP-5031 a run for best cook in containment.
Shaked ben yakar said, “I think they need
to explode him from the inside because maybe
there's one spot in his body that isn't invincible
and if they hurt it SCP-682 will die.”
The problem with SCP-682 isn’t necessarily
that it’s invincible, just hyper-adaptive
and hyper-regenerative.
As you may have seen in other videos, SCP-682
has been shot, dismembered, burned, frozen,
vaporized, blown up, partially eaten, and
even totally disintegrated.
But it always manages to come back, even from
the smallest specs of matter.
It would almost admirable… if it wasn’t
a perpetually-aggressive murder monster.
Brybot said, “Put it in 106's pocket dimension.”
This actually happened once during a containment
breach where the Old Man as well as SCP-953
the Polymorphic Humanoid ended up in 682’s
cell.
SCP-106 dragged them all into its pocket dimension
for a bit of the old ultra-violence, and when
they emerged, it was clear that they’d all
taken considerable damage.
SCP-682 wasn’t killed though, and 106 hasn’t
tried anything like that again since.
NonPlayerCactus said, “Trick him into killing
John Wick's dog.”
To be fair, if anyone could take this monster
down, it’d probably be John Wick.
Though SCP-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place.
And if he did manage to best John Wick?
Well we hate to think what a 682 with the
martial prowess and gun skills of John Wick
would be like.
Actually no, we don’t hate to think about
it, because it would be awesome.
These are just a little taster plate of the
huge and varied potential murder methods you’ve
devised for this terrible creature, but there
were just too many good ones, so we’ll have
to save the rest for another day.
Ah Skip, here we go again...
It’s time for us to take another crack at
putting SCP-682 six feet under, once and for
all.
If you’ve been following this channel for
any amount of time, then there’s one thing
you know for certain: SCP-682 is harder to
kill than pretty much, well, anything!
We’ve made multiple videos on the Foundation’s
failed attempts to finally terminate the beast,
and we made a video with some of your ideas
on how to finally slay the monster.
And considering you’re watching this video
right now, you can probably guess how that
went.
Now it’s time for one more run at the Death
Star: and once again it’s with your ideas
from comments and community post responses,
let’s see if any of them can help us finally
put this ill-tempered reptile to rest.
If we can’t…
well we’re not blaming you, but also it’s
your fault.
Let the community termination attempts commence!
Anais McBride suggested, “Ask the Witch
Child.”
SCP-239, also known as The Witch Child, is
one of the most dangerous and powerful anomalies
out there.
She’s a small girl with
unparalleled reality-warping
mental abilities, so powerful that her very
brainwaves alone can be passively fatal.
However, the problem is,
her power is so potentially
dangerous that she’s forever kept in a kind
of medically-induced anomalous coma.
Dr. Alto Clef thinks she’s so dangerous
he’s even campaigning to have her terminated.
As a result, the O5 Council has forbidden
any cross-testing between 682 and 239, fearing
the consequences of 239 gaining 682’s powers
and becoming a truly unstoppable threat capable
of causing an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
Syed Zamin Ali Shah Kazmi Mushadi suggested,
“Kill him with SCP-734.”
This is an interesting one.
SCP-734, also known as The Baby, is an anomaly
that causes a painful degenerative disease
that eventually disintegrates the entire body
and kills the victim if they so much as come
into contact with the baby or its fluids.
However, based on cross-tests with other,
similar “touch it and die” anomalies like
SCP-409 - the Contagious Crystal - we can
probably guess how exactly this would go down.
In all likelihood, the Baby’s anomalous
effects would infect and destroy large portions
of SCP-682’s body.
However, at this point, 682 would adapt to
the threat, and begin to reverse it and heal.
Even worse, it’s likely that 682 would steal
the ability for a limited time, and become
deadly to the touch.
Caden Griffin suggested, “Why don't you
use the Dragon Slayer to terminate 682?
It has proved itself many times in fights
with LSAs.”
SCP-5514, the Dragon Slayer, is essentially
a giant fighting robot designed to take down
killer kaijus with its
plethora of state-of-the-art
anomalous weapons and defenses.
However, we’d still argue that while it
could definitely help in immobilizing 682
during a rampage, it doesn’t have much of
a chance of actually killing it.
Let’s look at SCP-001, the Gate Guardian,
a supernatural warrior with a blade hotter
than the sun, capable of cleaving atoms in
half.
Even he couldn’t kill SCP-682.
So a robotic approximation with only a fraction
of the Gate Guardian’s power is probably
not going to have any real chance of killing
682.
ImAChuckster48 suggested, “Make it bite
its tongue so hard that it just destroys itself.”
While we can certainly attest from personal
experience that this really, really hurts,
we worry that if ever 682 bit its own tongue
really hard, it’d just drive it into a state
of murderous rage.
Though we do take a small piece of satisfaction
in knowing its tongue would probably be in
distress for a few minutes afterwards, it’s
unlikely to wipe out the beast once and for
all.
Liezel Rolle suggested, “How about we just
put SCP-682 in 2317's cell.”
SCP-2317 is an old wooden door that functions
as a portal into the domain of a planet-destroying
monster known as The Devourer of Worlds, a
being that many believe is associated with
the Scarlet King, and will inevitably escape
and cause an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
While you may be thinking, “Perhaps it’ll
kill 682”, it’s more likely that they’d
collaborate, seeing as they both want the
same thing.
Namely, to kill everyone.
If you let 682 in, chances are, it’ll come
back through that door with the Devourer right
on its tail - then, it’s all of our problems.
Guest123 116 suggested, “Drop him in Russia
so they can terminate him.”
The Foundation has technically already tried
this.
They dropped 682 into SCP-3930, a patch of
literal non-existence in Russia that causes
anything that goes inside of it to cease to
exist.
And afterwards?
He was fine!
So yeah, dropping him anywhere in Russia is
probably just going to get a bunch of innocent
Russian civilians killed.
Mysher said, “The Foundation shouldn't worry
about how to kill him, but how to stop his
ability to adapt.
I would suggest typing "Scp 682 no adaptability
juice" or something like that into SCP-294
and then kill him by any means, which SHOULD
kill him forever.”
An interesting theory, but what if he simply
adapts to SCP-682 no adaptability juice?
Then we’d really be in trouble...
MarioTGP said, “Give him a twitter account,
he'll be canceled instantly for his spicy
opinions.”
SCP-682 would cancel Twitter itself, for not
having opinions that are spicy enough.
Sorry, Jack.
SCP-096 - still sore about losing the battle,
we assume - said, “Let him fight the queen
of England.
After all, she’s immortal too.”
We definitely think it would be interesting
to see SCP-682 go head to head with the Queen
of England.
Based on all the knighting she does, we know
that she at least has a sword, though we don’t
know if that sword is as powerful as the one
wielded by the Gate Guardian.
But regardless of the outcome, the battle
would definitely change history.
Every history book would simply read: “SCP-682
Punched the Queen”, everything else would
just be a footnote.
Noah Cordero said, “Use SCP-2935 to kill
the lizard.
As you can see in the video, he will die.”
SCP-2935, also known as O’ Death, is probably
one of the scariest and deadliest SCPs out
there.
It killed an entire alternate dimension, including
an alternate SCP-682.
The problem is, putting our 682 into 2935’s
alternate reality could lead to the destruction
of our entire dimension.
Why’s that?
Because, if 682 was somehow able to return
to our world from the world of 2935, it could
bring the spirit of death itself back with
it and kill us all in the process.
Explorando con beto 1 suggested, “SCP 682
vs Lady Dimitrescu.”
While Resident Evil 8’s Lady Dimitrescu
has certainly captured all of our hearts,
we don’t think she’ll be bringing home
the W on this one.
Lady Dimitrescu has a powerful adaptive ability
of her own - with a high resistance to damage,
impressive regenerative abilities, and a number
of offensive capabilities, from huge claws
to a powerful dragon form.
However, considering she wasn’t even able
to defeat Ethan Winters, she probably wouldn’t
be able to defeat SCP-682, either.
However, in her dragon form, SCP-682 may finally
join the rest of us in developing a crush.
Or is that being crushed?
Anyway, moving on.
Jonathan Pecany suggested, “Just ask SCP
343 on how to destroy it, or even better,
ask if he could destroy it.”
It’s an idea so good that the Foundation
actually tried it, and it went about as well
as you can expect.
When the SCP known as God entered the containment
chamber, he couldn’t even see 682 in there,
as though the creature was somehow totally
invisible to him.
When God eventually got bored and left, they
told him that he was in there to destroy 682.
He simply replied, “He's not one of mine.
Deal with him yourself.”
Interpret that how you will.
12 Escobar Blancas Eddy Saul suggested, “They
could send him to Area 37 for The Sisters
to experiment with.”
SCP-1765, The Sisters, are a trio of terrifyingly
powerful reality warpers that have taken over
Area 37, and spend their days tormenting everyone
inside with their twisted experiments.
Using them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the Witch Child
or the Devourer of Worlds: If they decide
to team up rather than fighting, or the Sisters
take over 682, we’d all be effectively doomed.
Kiroyah suggested, “Would the ants from
SCP-743 tear 682 apart?”
The Foundation actually tried this, getting
682 to consume chocolate from the SCP-743
fountain, incurring the wrath of its flesh-eating
ants.
However, 682 developed an adaptation that
gave it a long, ant-eater-like tongue, that
it then used to consume the ants faster than
they could consume it.
And even worse, the chocolate seemed to enhance
its regenerative abilities even more for several
days afterwards.
Lol 2222 suggested, “Write the name in the
Death Note.”
Great idea.
We’ll put it into practice as soon as you
can tell us SCP-682’s real name.
It may come as a surprise, but its parents
didn’t actually name it the “Hard to Destroy
Reptile.”
Stephen Vierie suggested, “I thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant blender
and then when he is in small pieces put lava
in the blender so it will incinerate him then
put nuclear waste into the blender and repeat
that until there is no more left of him.”
After the cooking whisks last time, we feel
obliged to include at least one attempt to
kill SCP-682 with oversized kitchen equipment
in every video about him.
However, this attempt would probably go about
as well as the last one, we’re afraid.
Extreme physical trauma by conventional means
- like burning and dismemberment - has never
been successful in the past.
And the Foundation is extremely hesitant to
use anything radioactive on the beast, in
case it adapts and adds deadly radiation to
its own arsenal.
MrMaster IQ suggested, “Just take away his
plot armor.”
You can pry SCP-682’s plot armor from its
cold, dead claws, and as we’ve already learned,
making those claws cold and dead seems next
to impossible.
Moving on.
JC3 suggested, “HMMM IF ANYBODY CAN'T BEAT
THE UNDYING LIZARD WHY NOT OMNI MAN I MEAN
HE DID KILLED ALL THE GUARDIANS OF THE GLOBE
OF COURSE HE CAN KILL SCP-682.”
Omni-Man from the comic and TV series Invincible
is undeniably a formidable opponent, given
he’s able to destroy superhero teams, cities,
and even planets.
However, one of the few enemies to give Omni-Man
a genuine run for his money
is a genetically-enhanced
Kaiju known as Hail Mary.
Given that, first, 682 has taken on beings
stronger than Omni-Man - like the Gate Guardian
- and lived, and second, that Omni-Man has
struggled with monsters before - chances are,
he probably couldn’t permanently kill this
one, either.
Heycani Havea suggested, “Kill SCP-053,
then 682 will be sad and die.”
Wow, now that’s cold-blooded.
However, even if this did work, it’s important
for you to remember that it’s impossible
to actually kill SCP-053, also known as The
Child or the Little Girl.
Part of her anomalous abilities is that anyone
who attempts to kill her
will themselves immediately
die during the process - normally due to a
heart attack.
So this method would result in a pile of dead
Foundation personnel, and no progress.
Jerry Zhang said, “Mush peanut butter on
it.”
This would definitely work if SCP-682 has
some kind of severe peanut allergy.
After all, anaphylactic shock is no laughing
matter.
However, in the far more likely event that
this will have no effect on SCP-682, you will
likely just die with your hands covered in
peanut butter.
Andrew Mills suggested, “My idea?
Have several Xenomorphs, Predators, and Daleks
(yes that’s a Doctor Who reference) take
682 on.”
Once again, in all likelihood, this would
have no effect.
682 has survived blades and lasers - the primary
weapons of the Predators and Daleks - and
spends the majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid, so the xenomorph would hold
no surprises for it.
Sadly, this three-way teamup would be no match
for 682.
And even if they did defeat him, whoever wins,
we… well you know how it goes.
Matteo Huang suggested, “Maybe just destroy
reality.”
This.
This might be the thing that finally kills
SCP-682, but considering it’s already survived
being thrown into pure nothingness in Russia,
it may just result in it being one of the
only survivors of a full destruction of reality.
We, on the other hand, would all be killed.
Though in a sense, we wouldn’t have to deal
with SCP-682 anymore.
So maybe that’s a type of winning?
And finally, Blind Honor suggested, “Would
Saitama be a good way to eliminate it?
He is One Punch Man, after all.”
Of anyone we’ve covered in this series,
Saitama from One Punch Man would probably
be the most likely to kill SCP-682, especially
if he was taking the battle seriously.
After all, he has killed planet-destroying
monsters before with barely any effort.
The only real question is whether he could
even be bothered to come down to a Foundation
containment site and fight it.
Saitama hasn’t been known to be a very motivated
guy.
But of course, like with anything, there’s
the risk that 682 would survive and gain his
powers.
Which would be bad.
Awesome.
But bad.
Those blasted Foundation rats had done it
again...
SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile, sat
in its tank of highly concentrated acid and
seethed at the world it had been placed in.
And what a miserable, terrible world it was.
He hated it, and he hated every single soul
that occupied it - and especially the hypocritical
monsters in lab coats that ran this sham of
an organization.
Whenever the reptile wasn’t speaking - normally
to bark threats and profanities at its human
jailers - it was quietly listening, taking
everything in, and how the things it heard
made its blood boil more than the corrosive
fluid forever eating into its carapace.
What high-minded ideas these worthless apes
had about themselves: “We’re cold, not
cruel.”
Ha!
What a sick joke...
Every moment for the reptile was a different
kind of hell.
The baseline of existence was a certain dull,
fizzling pain as he melted as quickly as his
cells could divide.
His only reprieve from this was to be dragged
into a testing chamber for some even worse
pain: Perhaps burned, or sliced, or chewed
at by a mutant rabbit, or crushed by bananas,
or torn apart by wires and hooks, or beaten
and bashed by some mad swordsman, or having
his mind invaded and attacked by a rogue soul
in a cursed necklace.
If this was only “Cold”, then the reptile
hated to even imagine what the SCP Foundation
considered “Cruel.”
After all, there were monsters more powerful
than him out there.
The Hanged King or the Devourer Of Worlds
could handily destroy their wretched ball
of rock if they so chose to.
He wasn’t the most sadistic or evil of the
beasts these maniacs in white coats had faced.
Those who warred with him met a quick death
at his claws and fangs.
Would that nightmarish Old Man afford his
victims such a luxury?
Or that unstoppable psychopath in the old
police car?
And yet, it was his file that bore the addendum:
“SCP-682 must be destroyed as soon as possible.”
And why?
Seemingly only because he could take it, and
the Foundation always had new toys it wanted
to test on their favorite punching bag.
Of course, he attempted to escape, but wouldn’t
you?
Is freedom not an inalienable right?
The Foundation would cry, “But look at the
terrible crimes he’s committed!
Look at the lives he’s taken!”
as they always do.
Let he who is without sin draw the first acid
bath.
He knew, on some level, if he were to make
a tally, the Foundation’s crimes would far
outnumber his own.
The only difference was that they’d deluded
themselves into believing all acts of cruelty
are permissible in service of their “greater
good.”
If they all had but one head, the reptile
would claw it from their shoulders.
A group of incredibly well-armed and well-armored
guards entered the room, training all their
weapons on him.
He hadn’t summoned the energy to escape
today, and that meant only one thing: They
were going to take another swing at killing
him again.
Oh, goody.
Another attempt that would leave him momentarily
in absolute agony, and allow neither of them
to gain any ground.
He’d grown numb to attempts on his life
by now.
Whatever they had waiting for him in the other
room, he’d be ready for it.
The guards removed him from his acid bath,
and, while he was still trying to regenerate
his muscles and nerves enough to move, they
dragged him into the testing chamber.
It was always a mystery, wondering what they’d
be poking or prodding him with today.
But when he was first dragged into the chamber,
it was...
Empty.
Those were always the worst ones.
When he was left some sitting duck, waiting
for the Foundation, in their infinite malice,
to choose the form of the would-be destroyer.
What would be behind Door Number One...
A box.
A large, wooden box was pushed into the room,
and the door closed behind it.
How curious.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile began to approach
the box, sniffing at the air.
It made no sound in there, but something about
that smell.
Something...
eerily familiar...
It was different this time.
With a soft pop, the box fell apart, its walls
falling in different directions like the petals
of a blooming flower.
And the second the Hard to Destroy Reptile
saw what lurked inside, it felt an unfamiliar
cold barb of terror hook into the soft, warm
flesh of its heart.
The thing inside the box had been called SCP-173
by the SCP Foundation, but that wasn’t how
the reptile knew it.
It was a primordial nightmare.
An ancient horror.
The stone devil.
The killer in the dark.
The Koitern, which had mercilessly and gleefully
slaughtered so much of the reptile’s very
species, back when 682 was
known as the Atanti-ql-Paneu.
And here it was...
Ready to finish the job.
SCP-682 let out an involuntary screech of
pure horror and fled backwards, keeping its
eyes fixed on the monster at all times.
He moved back until he hit the far wall of
the containment chamber.
Until he could go no further.
His mind was flooded and his heart was racing.
He never thought he’d see this monster again.
He’d hoped it would never cross his path
again.
Perhaps he’d even held out hope that the
abomination had been slain, destroyed, scattered
to the winds.
And yet, here it was, looking at him.
The reptile called out, “You fools.
You have no idea what you’ve done.
This...
Thing, mark my words, it will be your ruin!
It will slaughter every single one of you!”
But its appeals to reason with its captors,
in their own interest, for once, fell on utterly
uninterested ears.
Six hours of this passed, the reptile spending
every second of it, for the first time in
a long time, fearing for his life.
A group of observing Foundation scientists
merely noted a peculiar reaction of distress
from 682 and ordered a decorated Mobile Task
Force sharpshooter with a Barrett 50 Caliber
Sniper Rifle
with armor-piercing rounds to initiate Phase
2 of the cross test.
In a sudden flash of sound
and pain, the sharpshooter
blew away both of SCP-682’s staring eyes.
The simultaneous instruction went out for
all observing members of personnel to avert
their gaze, just for a moment.
682 could certainly regenerate its eyes quickly,
but nothing was quite as fast as an unobserved
SCP-173.
The reptile screeched in pain as it heard
the monster snapping its body parts, leaving
it thoroughly mutilated.
When the group of observing scientists looked
back, they saw it - which is to say, SCP-173
- standing before a heavily damaged SCP-682,
as though incredibly proud of its handiwork.
Internally, 682 thanked a creator it despised
for the fact that the observers looked back
and spared it from the onslaught that soulless
stone monster had unleashed on it.
A scientist working for the Foundation would
later remark, “After review, it appears
SCP-173 was unable to do lethal damage to
SCP-682 due to a major difference in physical
size.
A possible repeat of this test may be made
if SCP-682 is damaged enough to reduce its
physical mass to a level equal with SCP-173.”
But 682 knew, deep down, this wasn’t the
truth.
It had nothing to do with physical size: If
the Koitern had truly willed it, he never
would have left that room.
The monster only wanted to extend the torment.
And this time, SCP-682 wouldn’t let him.
He regenerated, adapted, and came back ready.
682 developed a number of eyes, far more than
before, that remained fixed on SCP-173, paralyzing
it.
It crawled back up onto the wall and simply
stared.
Once again, the observing scientists ordered
the sharpshooter to take aim and open fire.
But this time, the bullets had no effect.
SCP-682 has developed a thick, clear carapace
over the surface of its new eyes, ensuring
that nothing would break its eye contact with
that murderous little monster.
This time, it would not lose.
But for all the time that 682 stared, 173
said nothing, as always.
It just stood there, the strange pattern of
its face, that nasty, bloody Rorschach splotch,
looked almost like a mocking smile.
It conceded nothing.
It seemed to say, “Go on.
Get an eyeful.
I have all the time in the universe, and everyone
looks away eventually, even you, Atanti-ql-Paneu.
Let the eternal silence of your brethren be
a lesson to you.
All you will hear is Crunch.”
682 kept up the staring contest for twelve
hours, before it was taken back to its acid
bath, thoroughly shaken by its experience.
It had always despised its terrible captors,
but now, a new shade of darkness had entered
its narrow emotional lexicon: Fear.
True fear.
An acknowledgment, deep down in its muscle
tissue and guts, that there was something
out there that could truly hurt it.
The terrible Koitern was alive and thirsty
for blood.
The researchers who’d conducted this test
considered it an interesting partial success.
While 682 was quaking in its tank thinking
about 173, they were brainstorming the best
move to take next, regarding potential pairings
between 682 and 173.
A plucky researcher noted that 096 had also
gotten SCP-682 on the ropes, so maybe they
should send in SCP-173 with a photo of SCP-096
taped to its chest.
A member of the O5 Council intervened before
this got too far, saying, “No.
Absolutely not.
Setting aside the problem of SCP-682, an SCP-173
that cannot be observed for fear of triggering
a response from SCP-096 is a self-perpetuating
catastrophe that the Foundation does not,
under any reasonable circumstances, have the
slightest desire to unleash.
Denied with vehemence.”
The researcher who’d suggested this idea
felt supremely embarrassed, and retired briefly
to one of the employee bathrooms to have a
good cry before returning to the brainstorming
session.
Researcher Maytus, a more experienced member
of personnel, had a stroke of genius.
He reminded the assembled researchers that
they’d recently performed another semi-successful
experiment on SCP-682: Using their deadly,
high-precision blades, they were able to slice
and dice 682 into a series of amorphous blobs.
Sure, these blobs may have attacked and killed
some D-Classes before reforming into the OG
Nasty Reptile, but each of these blobs were
the perfect size to be murdered by SCP-173.
It eliminated the size differential and put
these two on an even playing field, and on
that even playing field, it stood to reason
that SCP-173 might win.
The cross-test was greenlit and a researcher
named Dr. Shenron was put in charge of overseeing
the operations.
And this time, due to Foundation incompetence
and a greater degree of mental preparedness
by SCP-682, they were in for a complete disaster.
682 and 173 were brought into the same containment
chamber.
682 could feel the latent fear welling up
inside itself, so it did the thing that it
knew the best: It tried to stoke up its rage.
Its hatred.
The fury and spite that had kept it going
through so many torturous attempts on its
life.
It would not die at the hands of this stone
monster.
And if that was its destiny, then it would
ensure, with its dying wretched breaths, it
would destroy this terrible beast once and
for all.
It would shatter it and ensure it never put
itself back together.
Suddenly, the high-precision blades were deployed.
It was an endless volley of cutting that dashed
the two deadly anomalies to pieces like a
giant As Seen On TV Slap-Chop.
Because the machine had been calibrated for
its body, 682 was sliced into 12,000 perfect
cubes, and 173 had been cut into a pile of
lumpy, irregular chunks.
A vacuum system was then activated to separate
both anomalies into different chambers, so
173 could reform and begin the assault, but
miraculously for 682, the vacuum system failed.
Two D-Classes were sent in to recalibrate
the system, but things quickly got even worse.
Many of the 682 cubes formed the same gelatinous
masses that they did in the previous High
Precision Blades Test, and began attacking
and killing one of the D-Classes.
The other, naturally, turned to look at this
horrifying display - Which meant nobody was
paying attention to SCP-173.
Immediately, the Sculpture reformed and snapped
the surviving D-Class’ neck before turning
its attention to SCP-682.
The emergency incineration system failed,
so all the Foundation could hope for was Mutually
Assured Destruction until they got the situation
back under control.
However, the Foundation had underestimated
682’s intelligence and tactical reasoning.
While the gelatinous, mutated globs of its
flesh attacked 173, smashing and cracking
its concrete body as it killed and splattered
them, the remainder of 682’s flesh formed
a smaller version of itself, which began staring
at 173.
This froze the sculpture in place while the
mutated flesh monster smashed into it, slowly
breaking it down.
For the first time in as long as it could
remember, 682 felt genuine glee.
The thrill of revenge.
The glory of an ancient foe vanquished.
It would now slay the terrible Koitern, as
its ancestors had tried to do so many times
before, and failed.
But this reptile would not fail.
Until, of course, the SCP Foundation - monsters
that they were - decided to put their finger
on the scale.
The same Foundation Mobile Task Force sharpshooter
who’d been there during the first 173 cross-test
was still there, still ready to carry out
his duties.
On the order of the researchers, he fired
another two shots, blowing out the eyes of
this new, smaller 682.
While it regenerated its precious eyes, 173
went on a rampage, mercilessly slaughtering
every single one of the eyeless blobs of mutated
flesh.
It smashed each one beyond repair, until only
it and the smaller 682 remained.
Luckily for 682, its eyes regenerated, complete
with the familiar bulletproof covering, just
in time to hold back 173 from killing it.
The two remained locked in a staring contest
of pure hatred for a solid seventeen hours
before the test was eventually called off.
But the horrors continued!
Exhausted by the ordeal already, SCP-682 was
sedated and returned to its containment chamber
without incident, where it regenerated back
to its default state.
Things weren’t so easy with SCP-173.
While a team transported
it back to its containment
chamber, there was a power outage in the hall,
and things went dark.
And considering SCP-173, in addition to The
Sculpture and The Peanut, could also be nicknamed,
“Instant Killing Spree, Just Add Darkness!”
it won’t surprise you to hear there were
no survivors.
173 killed everyone in the hall, then escaped
out into the wider facility, causing a site-wide
containment breach and a
huge number of casualties.
The cause of the electrical short that kickstarted
this massacre was traced back to Dr. Shenron’s
tampering with the incinerator system.
This got the doctor formally reprimanded,
stripped of his titles and his memories, and
relieved of his duty.
But the worst was still very much to come
for everyone involved.
Including SCP-682.
Because the true terrifying potential of SCP-173
was soon going to be unleashed, and when that
happened, nowhere would be safe.
On what was otherwise a very normal day, in
a very normal procedure when a few D-Classes
were sent into SCP-173’s cell, something
extraordinary and terrible happened: SCP-173
multiplied.
Like a single-cell organism undergoing mitosis,
173 somehow just split into two equal copies
of itself.
Two D-Classes were killed
in this first duplication
event, but they were just the beginning.
Soon enough, people would look back so fondly
on the days when there were only a mere two
of these things.
The Foundation and 682, for
all their disagreements,
are very much alike.
Both are always vying for control over their
situations, and both achieve this through
understanding and adapting to whatever is
threatening them.
As SCP-173 continued to multiply, the Foundation
did what they could to adapt and regain control.
They tried to contain specific instances in
smaller containment units.
They tried to create new methods for permanent
observation.
They even tried shipping them off to the moon.
But none of it did any good.
SCP-173 continued to duplicate.
They escaped, began spreading further.
They killed half a million civilians in 48
hours, and believe us when we tell you they
were just getting started.
The ever-growing army of 173 instances went
on massive killing sprees every night, taking
out huge swathes of the civilian population
as they scrambled and panicked in the dark.
And they weren’t just going after civilians.
Evidently, much like 682, 173 had a grudge
against the SCP Foundation for all those decades
of imprisonment.
The 173 army began locating, surrounding,
and destroying entire Foundation containment
sites, and killing off all the staff and the
anomalies inside.
Of all the entities in containment that might
one day go XK and destroy the world as we
knew it, not many people had 173 on their
bingo card.
If only they’d listened to 682’s warnings
and reallocated their termination resources
to 173, things may have turned out differently.
And speaking of our scaly old foe, 682 sat
in an empty chamber.
It’d been days since anyone had come in
to check on it - All fled or dead from snapped
necks, one of the two.
He thought about escaping containment, but
given the bloodbaths going on outside, all
the time, what would even be the point?
All that was really left was time, and that
was a rapidly depleting resource.
He just needed to wait for that...
Thing to come and see him again.
SCP-682 blinked,
and there it was, standing before him, looking.
Blink.
And there was more.
So many of them.
So, so, so many.
Blink.
Surrounded on all sides by that terrible creature.
Too many to fight.
Too many to win.
Just waiting, watching, mocking him.
There was only one thing left to do.
Blink.
Hello, everyone!
If you’re a fan of SCP Explained, you’ll
know that we regularly post interesting questions
in our community tab, asking for responses
from you - our dear fans.
These have ranged from questions about specific
anomalies, like SCP-096, or your suggestions
on how we should actually kill SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile.
We’ve even asked you which anomalous powers
you’d want to have, and posed your questions
directly to SCP-343, also known as God, and
of course, the terrifying and infamous Scarlet
King.
But in our latest community question, asking
you about hypothetical crossovers between
the SCP Foundation and the weird, wild multiverse
of all fiction, you truly outdid yourself,
with thousands upon thousands of responses.
And we thought, rather than just making one
video selecting our favorites, we’d turn
each of our favorites into whole videos.
And how are we going to do that?
That’s when this wonderful state-of-the-art
gizmo comes into play!
You may remember the Anom-O-Tron 6000, our
incredibly advanced artificial intelligence-driven
supercomputer designed specifically to run
simulations for the SCP Foundation.
We’ve fed this computer data from countless
SCP Foundation experiments and cross tests,
and all the data from your suggestions.
This will allow the fine folks at the SCP
Foundation to explore any anomalous hypothetical,
without risking the lives of staff members
or civilians.
This brings us to our first simulation, suggested
in a huge number of comments: Could SCP-682
be Contained Within the Backrooms?
For those not in the know, the Backrooms is
an internet urban legend that’s spiraled
into a full-blown phenomenon.
It’s built on the premise that if you’re
not careful and enter certain
specific circumstances,
you can no clip out of our reality, and enter
a terrifying, multi-level alternate reality,
where you’re stalked by a variety of bizarre
and frightening creatures.
This could be a complete nightmare for your
average person, but how would it play out
if SCP-682, the endlessly angry Hard to Destroy
Reptile, found its way inside?
Also, for another Backrooms-related surprise,
stick around until the end of the video…
In the meantime, though, let’s boot up the
Anom-O-Tron and test this new scenario!
The worst had happened: Again.
SCP-682 had busted out of containment during
a cross test and started making a beeline
for the nearest populated area.
Several helicopters containing heavily-armed
MTF Nu-7, “Hammer Down”, members were
in hot pursuit, attempting to slow the vicious
reptile down with targeted sniper fire at
its legs.
But it seemed that these efforts were all
for naught: SCP-682 had already reached the
defunct industrial district on the edge of
a nearby city, and if the beast managed to
actually reach a populated area, all hell
would break loose.
That’s when they pulled out the heavy weaponry:
Miniguns mounted to the helicopters unleashed
a rain of hellfire down onto SCP-682.
However, 682 managed to dodge most of the
bullets and simply tank the rest.
Command authorized the use of heavy ordinance:
The helicopter’s missile launches.
They’d pick up the pieces afterwards, once
SCP-682 was back in containment.
However, the reptile had plans of its own.
It charged into a nearby abandoned chemical
plant to avoid the gunfire from above.
This was exactly what Hammer Down wanted.
The helicopters circled around the chemical
plant and unleashed a barrage of powerful
incendiary missiles, blowing the plant to
kingdom come in hopes of dragging an incapacitated
682 out of the rubble afterwards.
But when the smoke had cleared and only the
rubble was left, 682 was nowhere to be seen.
Even for the hardcore operatives of Hammer
Down, this caused an anxiety spike.
Had it tunneled into the ground?
Had it adapted to the attack by turning invisible
or getting tiny to escape?
It’d done all these things before.
Or after all the deranged attempts at putting
SCP-682 in the ground, had some light firebombing
killed the monster?
Whatever the case, they’d need to search,
in case SCP-682 popped up somewhere else and
started causing havoc.
If it was still alive - which it probably
was - they couldn’t rest on their laurels
until they’d found it again.
Meanwhile, SCP-682 woke up.
It felt groggy and irritated, its body resting
against an unpleasant, soggy carpet.
It licked the carpet - the moisture had the
distinct flavor of human spinal fluid, which
682 had tasted many times before.
The sickly yellow walls and incessant buzzing
from the fluorescent lights up above were
nauseating, and it gave 682 a nagging headache.
This only made 682’s default emotion - blistering
rage and hatred - even worse.
It began walking around, exploring this strange,
spatially anomalous environment.
Was this more of that frustrating Foundation
trickery?
Another one of those puerile “cross-tests”?
The last thing 682 remembered was running
at one of the walls in the chemical plant
- a wall that, in hindsight, seemed darker
than the others - but rather than shattering
through the brickwork, it was here now, in
this strange, tacky lobby that never seemed
to end.
It was like a kaleidoscope of empty, 1990s
office kitsch.
Endless worthless yellow walls arranged like
some labyrinthine, nonsensical maze, leading
nowhere and devoid of all life as SCP-682
wandered through it.
And of course, SCP-682 found it disgusting.
It was only on Level 0, and already, 682 hated
the Backrooms just as much as it hated our
dimension.
Someone or something had to pay for the crime
of inconveniencing it this way, and it would
happily turn this whole dimension inside out
just to find some beings to kill inside it.
Yes, that would be great fun…
SCP-682 began its frantic search for an exit,
evolving an innate sonar ability and picking
up speeds that would be impossible for human
beings.
This is the part where most people would go
mad, or die from hunger or thirst.
SCP-682?
Not so much.
It could keep searching, and searching, and
searching until the stars burned out in the
sky.
It would find its prey, somehow, and when
it did, it would put them through hell.
And as it turned out, this new universe rewarded
682’s dogged stubbornness, because when
it passed through a seemingly random hallway
after hours of searching, it was in a different
place entirely.
This place looked like some huge abandoned
warehouse complex with water shining off the
ground.
If 682 had more advanced knowledge of the
Backrooms, it would have known this was Level
1.
But the only number SCP-682 cared about was
body count, and in that regard, it would find
Level 1 to be a vast improvement.
Two groups of humans had established bases
in this level of the Backrooms: The Major
Explorer Group, a faction of professional
Backrooms traversers who maintained their
Base Alpha on this level, and the Backrooms
Nonaligned Trade Group, a commercial group
whose primary base is an economic hub on this
very level - A fortified city-like area with
a population of 412, which would, a few hours
after 682’s appearance, be a population
of zero.
But before all that, it felt like grabbing
a bite at the diner…
Tom’s Diner is a refuge for many people
trapped in the backrooms - a casual eatery
nestled into the cold warehouse environment
of Level 1, where people could get a warm
meal from Tom, a former cook who’s been
trapped in the Backroom for years.
SCP-682 was eager to be a part of this grand
tradition - But the Hard to Destroy Reptile
decided to buck the trend a little by just
devouring Tom himself.
From there, it decided to launch its rage-fueled
offensive against the various humanoid inhabitants
of the level.
Both the Major Explorers Group Base Alpha
and the Backrooms Nonaligned Trade Group Trade
Keep were heavily fortified against the kind
of entities these folks had gotten used to
facing in The Backrooms, but they were completely
unprepared for a creature of SCP-682’s sheer
power, intelligence, endurance, and ferocity.
The SCP Foundation had been studying the creature
for decades, with far more resources than
either of these two Backrooms-bound groups,
and they still had a hard time keeping the
beast consistently contained.
Sadly for the greatest bastions of human hope
in the Backrooms, SCP-682 swept through both
outposts in a matter of hours, killing everyone
there without an ounce of remorse.
The only person there it took its time with
was the final human being left in the decimated
remains of the Major Explorers Group Base
Alpha.
It grabbed the man by the throat and squeezed,
asking with its guttural, growing voice:
“You.
Were you and your dead brethren allied with
the SCP Foundation?”
Despite his fear, the Explorer told 682 that
he had never heard of the SCP Foundation.
Nor did he know what kind of entity 682 was.
“Hmm.
Then what is this place?
Tell me, and I might give you a quick death.”
The Explorer gave as good a response as he
could: 682 was trapped in the Backrooms, a
multi-level interdimensional nightmare filled
with dangerous creatures.
That made 682 curious - Dangerous creatures?
That could make an interesting challenge.
682 asked the Explorer how it could access
these other levels, and find these creatures,
and the Explorer explained that through exploring
these levels enough, anyone could “no clip”
into the next one.
It really was that simple.
With that, 682 knew all it needed to know
and carelessly murdered the final human being
of Level 1.
It had killed so many humans over its long
and twisted life - It was no different from
breathing air now, an utterly perfunctory
action.
It was eager to discover these other creatures
on the lower levels, and teach them a new
level of fear they’d never experienced…
682 stormed through the halls until it achieved
the next successful no clip into Level 2,
which manifested as a series of old, dilapidated
maintenance tunnels that seemed to stretch
on for millions of miles.
Wonderful.
There were humans here, too, apparently, but
who cared about them?
This was the first level to feature a smorgasbord
of “Entities”, ripe for the killing.
It sped through the tunnels, teeth, and fangs
borne, eager to deal death with gleeful abandon.
The first entities it encountered in the expansive
tunnels of Level 2 were a collection of beings
known as Crawlers: Insect-like creatures infected
with an extremely aggressive fungal growth.
Just getting close to them could present an
active risk to humans - Not so much for a
creature that could easily regenerate after
being tossed into the sun.
As the creatures tried to lunge, SCP-682 simply
crushed and devoured them with little effort.
They tasted a little stale, on account of
the fungus, but the chewiness was pleasing.
Hopefully, there would be more challenging
foes down in the tunnel than these mere insects,
SCP-682 thought to itself while journeying
deeper into the endless network of tunnels.
Soon enough, SCP-682 ventured into a section
of the tunnel engulfed in total darkness.
Its eyes quickly adjusted, developing immaculate
night vision.
That’s when it spotted another creature
sharing this little slice of darkness with
it: A pair of floating, glowing eyes and almost
cartoonish teeth, grinning like some maniacal
Looney Tune.
This is an entity known as a Smiler, and they’re
a terrifying threat to any humans venturing
through the Backrooms.
SCP-682…
Wasn’t impressed.
It began a perfect adaptation for the situation:
Its body began to glow, emitting incredible
levels of both heat and light, carving through
the darkness of the tunnel and causing the
Smiler to emit a terrible, piercing shriek.
The sheer heat of this new ability melted
sections of the Level 2 tunnels around SCP-682.
When the light finally dimmed down to slightly
more reasonable levels, where the Smiler once
stood was instead a fizzling black scorch
mark.
Another creature had painfully bitten the
dust, and SCP-682 was starting to have some
fun.
It took off further down into the tunnels,
looking forward to finding its next victim.
Sadly for SCP-682, it wouldn’t get to kill
the next set of victims.
A group of four Child Facelings - spooky,
faceless little girls who like to cut apart
their typically human victims with small objects
- were waiting a little further down the pipe.
However, when they felt SCP-682 approaching,
they almost sensed the power and cruelty of
the beast coming towards them.
Even being little monsters themselves, game
recognized game, and they knew that they needed
to get the hell out of there before the monster
arrived.
They climbed between the pipes on the tunnel
walls and skittered off into hiding places
deep in the dark.
Lucky for them, SCP-682 passed them and just
kept going.
What would be the point in wasting time on
these little morsels when there were apparently
so many other creatures to massacre down here?
Next, SCP-682 came across a truly pathetic
creature - Something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even
interacting
with.
It was a creature known as a “Clump”,
a strange bundle of living limbs that will
move at great speeds and attack its usually
human targets.
It tried to do the same to SCP-682, manically
flailing its many twisted limbs.
682 killed it in a single stomp and moved
on, feeling its own psychological equivalent
of pity - but not that much of it.
Not long after mercy-killing the Clump, SCP-682
came face to face with a series of Hounds
- mutant humanoids who travel on all fours,
behaving in a wolf-like fashion.
This would, of course, be the stuff of nightmares
for your average human being, but would be
far more likely to put a being like the Hard
to Destroy Reptile to sleep with sheer boredom.
Humans acting like dogs?
That makes them even more worthless, the creature
thought, as it charged forwards and began
tearing the group of Hounds to shreds.
Minutes later, it was splitting off into an
adjoining tunnel, searching for more easy
entertainment.
But the deeper SCP-682 made its way into the
bowels of Level 2, the more it approached
a truly horrifying realization: The creatures
it was slaughtering here were even more boring
than the ones the SCP Foundation ceaseless
threw at it back on its native reality - or
at least, the reality where they’d contained
it.
Back in that world, it had faced giant, flaming
demi-gods with swords hotter than the sun.
It had faced some pale, shrieking monstrosity
that didn’t seem to die no matter what the
reptile threw at it.
There was the dark, gooey old man, the Immortal
Warrior from the Black Coffin, and even the
all-devouring bunny rabbit.
Here, it was killing the same wretched selection
of beasts again and again, a truly pitiful
offering.
Was this really the best this world had to
offer?
Incidentally, the next creatures it found
were literally known as the Wretches by the
human inhabitants of The Backrooms.
They were fleshy, zombie-like creatures that
682 figured the Sarkicists back home might
enjoy.
It couldn’t believe it was thinking fondly
of that old place while it carved the monsters
to ribbons with its claws.
It missed its old enemies, like Dr. Bright,
Dr. Clef, and even that irritating yellow
blob of snot.
The more it tried to take its mind off the
old world by killing its way through this
ant farm of endless tunnels, the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic.
For example, there were the Plague Goblins,
impish little creatures with masks like that
of a Plague Doctor.
682 found itself thinking almost fondly about
SCP-049, while it listlessly ate the tiny,
mischievous creatures like a depressed person
binging an extra-large pack of chips.
Even their tiny squeaks as they crunched between
the reptile’s terrible teeth gave it no
joy.
What a bleak turn of events this had all turned
out to be.
As it wandered through the infinite tunnels,
killing creatures and even humans as it found
them, SCP-682 made a quiet promise to itself:
Somehow, someway, it would make its way back
to the universe it’d so recently departed.
It would leave the Backrooms, no matter how
many levels, a quiet, burning husk, and return
to the world of fools and fiends it had taken
for granted all this time.
A visit to the Backrooms had taught the Hard
to Destroy Reptile an all-too-human lesson:
Sometimes, you don’t know what you have
until it’s gone.
Sure, the SCP Foundation may have tried to
kill it in a new, bizarre, and increasingly
sadistic way every single day, but that variety
was the spice of life.
It would return home someday, it knew that
much - But of course, a lot of creatures and
people would need to die before then.
But if that’s what it took, well, so be
it.
SCP-682 licked its dagger-like fangs, and
kept crawling…
Another day, another failed attempt at death.
If SCP-682 had anything even resembling a
sense of humor, he might ask for it to be
printed on a motivational poster and stuck
to the side of his containment chamber, where
he eternally melts and regrows at the mercy
of high-concentration acid.
They’d just cross-tested him with Able.
Again.
Unlike some of the others he’d been forced
to face, that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn’t intelligent enough to fear.
He’d always come back, just as stupid and
violent.
This encounter had left the Hard to Destroy
Reptile at thirty percent of his previous
body mass, bloody and bashed.
He’d survived the encounter.
He always survived.
They brought what was left of him back to
his cell in a forklift.
A blasted forklift!
How could it even be more humiliating?
As his eyes started to grow back in his head,
he could swear he even saw one of the technicians
laughing at him.
His name tag read, “Agent Nigel Kelly.”
Noted. 682 would specifically hunt down and
kill him the next time he breached.
Of course, every single day, he plotted revenge
against the human race - along with everything
else.
But the sum they owed in pain, blood, and
despair could never be repaid in full.
After all, every single one of them
- except Dr. Bright -
could only really die once.
They’d brought 682 to the precipice a thousand
times, only for his own body to cheat him,
and deprive him of the sweet release of death.
And if the Foundation had their way, it would
be done a thousand times more, and they wouldn’t
even stop there.
682 couldn’t even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to deal
a blow even comparable to the one he had faced.
All he could do was dream.
Dream of a reckoning that would turn the tables.
Something that would plunge humanity into
the state of constant pain and terror that
had been all he’d ever known since these
fumbling sadists in white coats had locked
him up here.
What a beautiful day that would be...
Little did SCP-682 know, that very day was
about to break.
Miles and miles away from the facility where
SCP-682 was kept - after all, orders from
the O5 Council have hard mandates on the minimum
distances between people and a site holding
a monster as volatile as 682 - parents watched
their children laughing and frolicking in
an idyllic playground.
Some squealed with glee as they descended
the slide.
Some of the more ambitious little tykes tried
to go over the bar on the swings.
Others waited in line for some delicious soft
serve at a parked Ice Cream truck.
One mother bought an ice cream cone and walked
over to a nearby bench, where she began to
enjoy her delicious frozen treat.
It was a remarkably hot day out and a little
ice cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied.
You could see the distant air wobbling in
the heat.
Already, her ice cream was starting to melt,
white rivulets dribbling down the sides of
the cone and onto her hands.
Suddenly, almost imperceptibly, the quality
of the light shifted.
The kind of thing you’d dismiss as a trick
of the eyes and forget just as quickly, were
it not for the catastrophic effects that were
about to unfold.
As the woman leaned forward to lick her melting
ice cream, something dripped onto her skirt.
But, as she looked down, she slowly realized
that what dripped onto her wasn’t the pure
white of her ice cream: It was the exact same
tone as her skin.
She felt a terrible burning sensation all
through her body.
The most horrible, debilitating pain she’d
ever experienced, like every cell in her body
was screaming and trying to make a break for
it.
She turned to the other parents sitting near
the playground.
They were screaming too.
Each collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness, different parts of their body falling
at different speeds as they transitioned through
states of matter.
When they hit the ground, they were taking
on a liquid state.
Screaming, worthless, boneless blobs.
The woman even saw her own arm wilting like
a time lapse video of a dying flower.
She dripped and sluiced through the cracks
in the bench, until nothing recognizably human
was left.
Only a soggy ice cream cone sitting uneaten.
In an instant, billions of screams rang out
over planet earth.
Day had broken.
Things would never, ever be the same again,
as almost half of humanity instantaneously
took on a liquid state.
Needless to say, with the most dangerous and
far-reaching anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind of
warning, the SCP Foundation was incredibly
busy.
This would take some unprecedented action.
The members of the O5 Council who weren’t
melted during the initial blast convened over
secure video link while sequestering themselves
underground.
In what amounted to multiple human lifetimes
of some of the most high-pressure choices
imaginable, they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the SCP Foundation.
In the service of all mankind, they would
now break the masquerade.
The SCP Foundation would, at long last, step
out of the shadows to save the rest of humanity
from the tyranny of the light.
Broadcasts went out all over the globe.
Every TV screen, every livestream, every radio
broadcast was commandeered.
They gave instructions based on the scattered
intel they had.
For some reason, the sun had turned against
them.
Exposure would lead to any biological creatures
melting away into sentient piles of flesh-colored
sludge.
People would remain indoors and away from
any light sources.
All windows must remain covered.
Travel only at night, and even then, heavily
covered with protective gear.
There can only be one objective for whoever
is left: Make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek refuge
inside.
If anyone could figure out the answer to this
terrifying existential riddle, it would be
the SCP Foundation.
Anyone who was exposed should be considered
lost.
While, as always, the SCP Foundation did all
they could to project a sense of control over
the situation, on the inside, it was pandemonium.
Somehow, despite everything, this event had
taken all of them by surprise.
How could anyone have predicted that the cradle
of our solar system’s delicate living balance
would suddenly become a meat grinder?
A huge number of Foundation operatives were
wiped out in the initial exposure.
Global communication infrastructure had been
devastated.
It was pure chaos.
And to SCP-682, as another evil tactician
once put it, chaos was a ladder.
From the inside of his acid tank, 682 could
sense the fear and pain suddenly exuding from
his surrounding environment.
It was greater than ever before.
What was happening out there?
This was no average containment breach.
Something was really, really happening out
there.
682 began to adapt and finely attune its hearing,
until it could pick up chatter from outside.
“Maybe we can convert some of the D-Class
barracks into serviceable bunkers for the
refugees?
It’s not like we’re prepared for this
kind of capacity!”
“Oh god, oh god, we’ve lost Site 7, Site
10, Site 23, Site 40, Site 52...”
“Death toll looks to be in the billions.
Well, we don’t know if they’re dead, technically.
But they’re sure as hell not human anymore...”
“This is the Big One.
This is it.
XK-Class.
Even 2000 is unaccounted for.
Is O5 crazy that they think we fight the freaking
sun!?”
Needless to say, 682’s curiosity was piqued.
Anything that could light a fire under the
Foundation like this was something he could
enjoy.
And, with his impressively strategic intellect,
he intuited that a time of great strife for
the Foundation would be the perfect time to
breach containment.
Cause whenever there’s violence, fear, and
chaos on a mass scale, SCP-682 will be there,
causing it.
682 began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful alkaline
substance.
Little by little, the alkaline neutralized
the acid surrounding him, turning it into
little more than plain water.
He then converted his internal systems to
have extreme endothermic rather than exothermic
properties, causing his surrounding temperature
to drop rapidly, until all the water in the
tank completely froze around him.
The ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment
unit, busting the rivets of the metal frame
and shattering the reinforced glass.
With this goal achieved, 682 raised his internal
temperatures to incredible highs, melting
the ice around him.
Once again, he was free, and ready for some
good, old-fashioned carnage and mayhem.
Perhaps he could get a better handle on this
strange new situation, too.
It was all rather exciting.
Just a girl with goals huh?
SCP Foundation personnel were already running
around like ants trying desperately to avoid
the caustic laser beam of the magnifying glass.
You can only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through the
wall, Kool-Aid man style, and began to ruthlessly
massacre everyone around him.
Just one of those days, you know?
The typical order during a 682 containment
breach is to dispatch all available units
to get him back under control.
The issue with this particular containment
breach was that, given the human population
was very rapidly being melted and they were
the only ones who could potentially save the
rest, they didn’t really have any available
units to pursue and recontain 682.
For once, he really wasn’t a priority, and
that meant terrible things for whoever he
ran into.
682 slaughtered his way through any researchers
or guards who dared to get in his way.
Disgusting creatures, really.
Better off dead.
He clawed and bit and tore and crushed with
almost childlike glee, leaving great piles
of bodies in his wake.
All the while, he was pondering the things
he heard those Foundation drones saying.
Something about the sun and an XK-Class scenario.
Interesting. 682 also observed that any apertures
that could potentially allow light into the
facility had also been shuttered.
Perhaps they weren’t overreacting this time,
like they always did with him.
Maybe they were dealing with some kind of
phenomenon that would now cast this wretched
world and those who lived in it into the void.
Wouldn’t that be a fitting karmic fate for
them all.
Still, 682’s bloodlust didn’t outweigh
his logic.
He needed to know more about this situation
before proceeding.
And in this, maybe he could kill two Foundation
birds with one stone...
Elsewhere in the building, alarms blared,
the air was suffused with panicked voices
and frequent screams.
Nobody knew what was going on, not really.
They’d only gotten details here and there,
and the details they’d received were terrifying.
All their families and loved ones outside...
Probably gone.
So many of the people and so much of the world
they’d been fighting for, risking it all
for, had disappeared in an instant.
Carried to hell on a ray of sunshine.
Why were they still here?
Was this horror not truly uncontainable?
These questions were swimming through the
mind of Agent Nigel Kelly as he stood alone
in his office, almost catatonic.
He’d had friends and family on the outside,
all likely reduced to those horrible fleshy
blobs.
He was alone in the world.
Risking his life for nothing.
How could this get any worse?
His mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again.
And the universe gave him an answer, in the
form of a deep, reptilian voice saying, “Found
you...” into his ear from behind.
He turned with a shriek to see the terrible
eyes of SCP-682 staring into his own.
Before he could try to flee or reach for a
weapon that he knew would only mildly annoy
the already furious beast, 682 reached out
with a massive, clawed hand and grabbed him
by the torso, lifting him up into the air.
The creature was gripping so tight he could
feel his ribs starting to crack.
“You laughed at me, Agent Kelly,” the
monster hissed.
“Am I funny to you?
Do I seem like the type to tell jokes?
Do you feel like laughing now?”
Agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his life,
fighting for his next breath from the crushing
squeeze of the creature’s terrible hand.
682 roared at him to be silent and ordered
him to tell him everything he knew about the
situation going on outside.
If the information was useful, 682 might show
his thought-to-be-non-existent magnanimous
side, and let Agent Kelly live.
Of course, Agent Kelly didn’t fancy his
chances, but what other choice did he have?
He told 682 that the higher-ups were calling
this SCP-001: When Day Breaks.
The sun had gone rogue somehow, and being
in contact with any kind of sunlight would
now cause people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying, living sludge.
And it wasn’t just people.
The condition also affected anomalies, and
interestingly, it appeared to negate all previous
anomalous effects - so 682’s adaptational
ability may not even save it if it was exposed.
He’d told 682 everything he knew.
“Are you going to let me live?”
Agent Kelly asked, struggling to breathe.
682’s terrible maw twisted into what might
have been a smile.
“Oh, Agent Kelly,” he said, with unsettling
joy.
“That was just a joke.
Didn’t you find that one funny?”
A terrible scream emanated from the Agent’s
office.
If one good thing could be said for what happened
to Agent Kelly that day, at least he didn’t
live long enough to see the ravages of the
terrible sun first hand.
682 began to formulate a plan.
He took Agent Kelly’s wristwatch and integrated
it into his body, so he’d have a permanent
internal clock.
It was the middle of summer, so the sun would
have reliably set at 9 PM and would likely
begin its rise at around 5 AM.
It would be relatively easy to avoid the sun,
all things considered.
For lack of a more eloquent way to put it,
when it comes to adapting to new threats,
SCP-682 is simply built different.
After slaughtering a few other members of
SCP Foundation staff for the road - Hey, it’s
not like anyone was fit to stop him - 682
began enacting the next phase of his plan.
His body grew a thick, smooth carapace, and
his front set of limbs began to grow, his
muscles bulging and his claws growing, the
tips turning into sharp, flat scoops.
With sudden and tremendous force, 682 began
boring his way into the ground.
Tunneling, clawing through concrete and dirt
with absolute ease.
Normally, the SCP Foundation would have deployed
high-tech seismic sensors and the kind of
tunnel-boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture him.
But during the endless horrors of the breaking
day, he had carte blanche to escape and live
it up in the ruins of this rapidly dying world.
Eventually, 682 had bored his way into a roomy
sewer pipe, the perfect place to wait out
a few hours.
Up above, so many millions screamed, either
in fear or in agony.
There had been some new developments that
the SCP Foundation had been yet to account
for.
While they knew that those melted by the rogue
sun were technically alive and trapped in
a permanent state of
suffering, what the Foundation
didn’t know was that these former humans
were incredibly dangerous in their own right.
The sun hadn’t just irreparably warped their
bodies, it had also irreparably warped their
minds.
It has enslaved them.
Made them zealots.
Acolytes.
They developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant, fleshy masses, driven by the single-minded
purpose of finding victims and dragging them
out into the light, where they too could be
converted into these terrible fleshy creatures
and add to the masses.
They were the rogue sun’s boots on the ground,
metaphorically speaking.
And now, they were the Foundation’s greatest
challenge in getting a handle on this situation
again.
Before, it was just encouraging people to
avoid the sun.
Now, the sun was actively trying to increase
its exposure.
But 682, who was having a relaxing evening
not being melted for once down in the sewers,
couldn’t care less.
He was having the most calming few hours he’d
had in years.
He waited, checking the time, making sure
that it would be dark before he began tunneling
back up to the surface world.
He surfaced in the middle of a city, miles
away from the Foundation facility he’d spend
so many decades being tortured in.
He tasted the cool night air and observed
the desolation that had been wrought all around
him.
Buildings were on fire.
Cars were crashed and overturned.
The ground was cracked.
Garbled SCP Foundation
Public Service Announcements
played to nobody in the broken display windows
of electronic stores.
Giant wads of human flesh roamed, slithering
around, searching for new victims.
One noticed 682 and began to approach him,
gibbering madly in a chorus of strange voices.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile wasted no time
in attacking.
It tore apart most of the hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks.
The form may have been different, but it still
tasted like human flesh, and SCP-682 savored
every single bite.
It would be so simple.
These blobs of idiotic flesh were so easy
to kill, and there would be so many terrified
humans in this devastated world, hiding away
in dark places, holding out the hope that
maybe they could reach the safety of a Foundation
facility.
682 chuckled at the very thought.
Foolish hope would drown in an endless well
of black, caustic despair.
He would find them.
He would rest underground in the day and then
hunt them in the dark.
They would all die screaming, bloodying his
claws and fangs.
Nothing and nobody would stop him.
He looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little louder.
It was just...
Delightful.
Another day, another failed attempt to execute
SCP-682 - The infamous Hard To Destroy Reptile.
The most recent attempt was SCP-272, an Old
Iron Nail with the ability to pin people’s
shadows to the ground and tear them to shreds
when different configurations of light make
their shadows go haywire.
Just when it seemed like 272 and a high-powered
disco ball might be the
thing to win the Foundation’s
war against the misanthropic lizard, it did
what it always did: Pulled out a trump card,
and ruined everything.
Its body evolved a sudden, intense bioluminescence
that completely eliminated the beast’s shadow
by overpowering all other light sources in
the room.
This not only rendered the Foundation’s
strobe lights utterly useless, but blinded
several members of D-Class personnel who were
sent in to check on the beast during testing.
This resulted, predictably, in another Big,
Fat L for the SCP Foundation.
682: 435, Foundation: 0.
And nobody was more frustrated by this than
Dr. Samet.
Samet was a Foundation greenhorn with big
ambitions.
Like every jerk at the office, he was less
concerned with doing his job right, and far
more concerned with climbing the corporate
ladder.
Samet had done all he could to cozy up to
Site Directors and even the Overseers far
above, all with the goal of someday getting
a seat at their high table.
But as any SCP fans know, they’re not just
giving out positions on or just under the
O5 Council.
To swing something like that, you need to
really make an impression.
You need to wow them.
And what would be a better way to do that
than being the person who killed SCP-682?
Surely, if he actually buried that beast,
they’d hand him the keys to the proverbial
castle.
So Dr. Samet had done everything he could
to get reassigned to the 682 termination effort,
and only now was he realizing just how in
over his head he truly was.
Dr. Samet needed help from a higher power.
If he even hoped of beating SCP-682, the man
needed God on his side.
Thankfully, they just so happened to have
God chilling out in his containment cell in
Site 17.
Perhaps, through enlisting the help of earth’s
divine arbiter, he could bring an end to the
scourge of SCP-682 and rocket himself to success
in the process.
However, while Dr. Samet may have been arrogant,
he wasn’t completely delusional.
He knew that he didn’t have the standing
to address SCP-343 directly, much less to
ask him for a hand in destroying SCP-682.
He’d need a go-between.
Someone with tenure, someone who commanded
respect among SCP Foundation staff as well
as the very anomalies they governed.
Perhaps someone who was a little bit anomalous
themselves…
And who better fits this description than
the living legend, Dr. Jack Bright?
Dr. Samet had, of course, read the doctor’s
personnel files.
Everybody at the Foundation knew about Dr.
Bright’s exploits - From what he’s done,
to the various things he isn’t allowed to
do, which we’ll cover in a future video.
He also dug up the SCP-963 files: The anomalous
medallion keeping Dr. Bright alive, whether
he likes it or not.
While a discussion of the exact nature of
the medallion isn’t something you’d want
to have in front of Dr. Bright himself - After
all, it’s a touchy subject - you could make
the argument that the medallion is the real
him.
It’s where his soul is condemned to spend
perhaps the rest of eternity, killing and
stealing the body of anyone or anything that
touched it.
He’d become an immortal parasite, destined
to take the finite lives of others while his
own marches on forever.
Remind you of anyone?
Dr. Samet got into contact with Dr. Bright
and explained his plan: With Bright’s help,
he’d recruit SCP-343, and bring the very
wrath of God down onto the Hard to Destroy
Reptile.
Of course, while Dr. Samet naturally assumed
himself to be the smartest person in the room,
Dr. Bright had a more realistic assessment
of the ambitious young turk’s skills.
He saw Samet for what he truly was: A climber,
a buttkisser, a greedy, power-hungry bureaucrat
wearing a lab coat, and he thought that made
him a researcher?
It was laughable.
What Dr. Bright found less funny, though,
was Dr. Samet’s insistence on calling him
“SCP-963.”
There’s a lot to know about Dr. Bright,
but one thing you should definitely commit
to memory is that you should never, under
any circumstances, call Dr. Bright SCP-963.
And if you were forever entwined with a necklace
that doomed you to watch everyone you know
and love age and die, while depriving you
of that same release, you’d probably resent
being associated with it, too.
Dr. Bright did agree to participate in Dr.
Samet’s harebrained termination scheme,
but with a warning that he did not give lightly:
If ever Dr. Samet called him 963 again, he
would have one of his own loyal team members
- nicknamed The Lucky Bunch, for their high
survival rate compared to other Foundation
research teams - shoot him in the foot.
Dr. Bright steeled himself and entered 343’s
containment cell, where the playful deity
had taken the form of the late comedian George
Burns, complete with his trademark glasses
and half-smoked stogy.
They made small talk, with 343 delivering
his usual high-handed, cryptic parables about
his plans for Dr. Bright, and everybody else.
He even momentarily teased the idea of freeing
him from his curse.
But Dr. Bright knew better than to buy into
these fairy tales.
He talked SCP-343 into a cross test, but didn’t
tell him that it was with 682, or that he
was expected to terminate it.
That was better left as a surprise.
Dr. Samet and Dr. Bright stood in the observation
area outside the cross-testing chamber.
Samet was giddy with excitement and confidence
in this new experiment.
Dr. Bright’s reactions were a hell of a
lot more measured.
He’d been working at the Foundation long
enough now to know that terminating SCP-682
was a fool’s errand.
The only researchers still intent on trying
it were doing so out of stubbornness and ego.
And when 343 and 682 were released into the
chamber, Dr. Bright’s healthy pessimism
was more than justified.
682 attacked a nearby door, attempting to
breach containment, while 343 looked around,
confused and seemingly unable to see anything.
When he was ordered to kill 682, he was shocked
to learn 682 was even in the room.
He stormed off moments later in a huff, saying,
“He's not one of mine.
Deal with him yourself.”
Dr. Bright was unsurprised.
Dr. Samet was shocked and furious.
How could this have failed?
They literally had God on their side!
This setback would seriously compromise his
chances of rising through the ranks, unless
he found a quick way to make the best out
of a bad situation and save face.
Without even thinking, he turned to Dr. Bright
and said:
“Fine.
It didn't work.
Doesn't matter.
Get yourself ready 963, you're going in.”
So it was decided.
Dr. Bright himself would face off with SCP-682
in SCP-343’s place.
Dr. Bright was a betting man, he loved a good
game of chance, and he estimated that his
odds of succeeding were exceptionally low.
But what would be the point in refusing?
Even if he couldn’t kill SCP-682, perhaps
he would get lucky, and the reptile would
kill him instead.
So many enticing possibilities.
Dr. Bright left to prepare for the coming
battle.
And, because nobody would say that Dr. Bright
wasn’t a man of his word, he had one of
his assistants shoot Dr. Samet in the foot.
A few days later, Dr. Bright, Dr. Samet - Now
in a wheelchair while he recovered from his
unfortunate foot injury - and a collection
of other researchers, including Dr. Sophia
Light, were convened in a conference room,
planning out their assault on SCP-682.
A mechanical “staff” of sorts was laying
on the table in front of him, a kind of powerful
taser capable of firing out painful bolts
of electricity.
It would be the only object Dr. Bright carried
into the chamber with him that day.
But only as a way of getting 682’s attention,
not as a weapon.
The true weapon was SCP-963.
The plan was simple: SCP-682 would eat Dr.
Bright, and the power of SCP-963 would destroy
it from within.
As anyone with an awareness of 963’s anomalous
properties could tell you, for most living
beings, touching the medallion results in
immediate brain death,
followed by the consciousness
of Dr. Bright inhabiting your mindless body.
If they could get this phenomenon to work
for SCP-682, perhaps, with Dr. Bright’s
mind in 682’s body, could they now end the
life of this wretched beast once and for all?
Like with all matters involving SCP-682 and
Dr. Bright, it was most likely not going to
be so simple.
When Dr. Bright entered the test chamber with
682, as Dr. Samet and the others watched from
the observation room, the results were sudden
and violent.
Dr. Bright zapped the monster
with his electro-staff,
and it came charging for him, a terrible fury
of teeth and claws.
Dr. Bright had died so many times, and yet,
he couldn’t even recall many experiences
more unpleasant than this.
And as 682’s interior flesh met SCP-963…
Dr. Bright woke up in the middle of a strange
new place.
There was a man standing over him that looked
oddly familiar, except for the strange chainmail
hauberk he was wearing.
When Dr. Bright found his feet, he recognized
the man: It was a D-Class.
In fact, the first body he’d ever inhabited
after his soul fused with SCP-963.
But he wasn’t alone here.
There were so many people, all of them wearing
the same chainmail, and carrying the same
electro-staffs that Dr. Bright had carried
into the chamber with him.
Little by little, he recognized every single
one of the faces: They were all people whose
bodies he’d taken.
Whose lives he’d cut short, to further his
own.
He looked around and saw more bizarre sights:
A grand castle, structured like a deranged
Escher painting.
And up above, drowning out the sky, was a
great, reptilian behemoth, like SCP-682 on
steroids, made entirely from barbecue sauce.
The D-Class broke the surreal news: None of
this was real, it was a fantasy his mind had
concocted to help him cope with his consciousness
bonding with SCP-682.
A more palatable way of perceiving his new
reality.
And if he ever wanted to get out and be himself
again, he would need to fight and conquer
the beast within.
Dr. Bright joined forces with his past victims,
including one former Level 2 Researcher, Damon
Smith.
Together, using their electro-staffs, Bright
and his army of mental constructs blasted
the great monster in the sky from the safe
confines of the castle.
However, things weren’t quite as safe as
Dr. Bright had first imagined.
The massive creature descended upon them,
tearing the castle to shreds with its huge
claws.
The construct of Damon Smith was devoured
in the process.
Dr. Bright’s brief illusion of victory was
soon stifled by one immutable fact: You could
not defeat SCP-682.
He retreated from the monster into the darkness
of his own nightmares.
From there, he woke up.
Dr. Bright was in a hospital bed, the medallion
attached to a new body after 682’s body
had rejected it.
He was greeted by Dr. Sophia Light and a member
of the O5 Council.
Dr. Bright had effectively been gone for days.
When he asked what happened on the outside,
he was told that 682 had entered a 36-hour
coma, before growing massive claws and tunneling
out of containment, where it caused a massive
breach.
Though strangely, upon breaking out of the
chamber, it only attacked one researcher…
And in unrelated news, Dr. Samet had been
taken off the 682 case.
It didn’t take long for things to return
to normal for Dr. Bright - Well, as normal
as life can be when you’re a man as strange
as him - but while few would notice it, 682
was left altered.
It had taken a souvenir from Dr. Bright: Fragments
of the consciousness of Damon Smith.
It felt his pain, his fear.
It tasted it, dissected it, and now understood
it.
And when the opportunity presented itself
once more, as it always did, he couldn’t
wait to inflict it on others...
Able wandered through the sands, a lone warrior,
dragging a long, dark sword behind him, his
black cloak flowing in the gentle breeze.
The sword was thirsty.
It’d been too long since it tasted blood.
What had it been?
A day since he cut down ten men in a tavern
without breaking a sweat?
They’d bled and screamed like pigs as he’d
diced them into bloody chunks.
He couldn’t remember their faces.
They hadn’t earned that.
Very few combatants had been remarkable enough
to warrant committing to memory.
It was all just more dead flesh.
He took a sip from his canteen and sighed.
Did this world hold no more challenges?
What a boring eternity was laying out before
him.
His burden as the greatest warrior of all
time weighed on him heavier than the chain.
It was old and rusty, levered over his shoulder
and grasped in one bloody hand.
About fifteen feet behind him, the chain was
connected to a dark, stone sarcophagus that
was as much a part of him as his eyes, skin,
or heart.
If ever he was slain in the glorious heat
of battle, he’d rise out of it, ready to
fight and kill another day.
All because of the actions of his worthless,
good for nothing brother…
He looked up when he heard the rush of footsteps
and the clanking of armor.
Warriors - or whatever passed for them around
here - about twenty of them, circled all around
him.
Yes, oh yes.
His grip tightened around his sword.
One of the warriors called out something about
him being under arrest, by order of the king,
for murders beyond counting.
Able couldn’t help but yawn.
Words, words, words.
Why even bother?
He dropped the chain, and in one fluid motion,
he threw his sword.
In a fraction of a second, it’d pierced
the armor of the chattering man, spearing
him through his formerly beating heart.
The scream died in his throat, he fell to
his knees, then collapsed entirely.
The other soldiers sent to kill or apprehend
him turned to their fallen leader and gasped.
It was that little gasp,
that moment of distraction,
that sealed their fates.
Able’s face cracked into a whisper of a
grin, as he drew two long daggers from the
darkness of his coat.
He’d at least try to have fun with this…
Before the others could even get over their
leader’s sudden death, Able had vaulted
forward and begun his delicate dance of slaughter.
Every swing found its way through armor and
into skin.
He sliced throats, cleaved off heads, parried
blows, and pierced hearts.
There was barely a single scream.
Able killed too quick for screams.
In what would seem like the blink of an eye
for some, the soldiers around Able fell.
Most dead, the rest dying.
Some looked up to him in their dying moments,
in terrified awe at the efficacy of their
killer.
In their dying moments, they knew that they
never had a chance.
They might as well have faced the glistening
scythe of death himself on the battlefield.
Able, on the other hand, rolled his eyes and
sighed.
Another pathetic waste of time.
He sensed movement in the corner of his eye:
One of the wounded soldiers was limping to
his feet, trying to use the sword to lever
himself off of the ground.
With a flick of each wrist, Able tossed his
knives into the man, killing him instantly.
It really was that easy.
“Your attempt to kill me does not offend
me,” he said, to whoever was still able
to hear.
“What offends me is that they would send
so few, and that those few would be such pitiful
excuses for soldiers.
This wasn’t a battle - It was a mercy killing.”
He was ready to turn around, grab the chain,
and carry on walking, when he felt a sudden
pain in his back.
There was a slight whistle, then another sharp
spike of pain.
There were now two arrows sticking out of
his back.
Able turned, surprised, and saw a much larger
force standing behind him.
Swordsmen, archers, men with clubs and axes
and chains.
The ones he’d killed were little more than
a distraction.
This was the real threat.
This was the real army.
Perhaps, these fools would give him some actual
exercise.
He reached into his cloak and pulled out a
mighty obsidian battle axe.
At the very least, he’d try to have a little
fun turning this fighting force into cold
cuts.
A fog of arrows sailed through the air as
he charged forwards, perforating his body,
but the injuries didn’t slow him down.
He lunged, slashed, and cleaved.
Even as the weapons struck him, he carried
on, killing person after person.
At times, it was almost exciting - Almost,
but not quite.
By the time he was done, none were left standing.
Thirty arrows were sticking out of him.
He’d been cut deep by more weapons than
he could count on his fingers and toes.
He was breathing deeply, scarred chest pumping
up and down.
He coughed blood and cracked his neck back
into place.
They might’ve cut him a little too deep
this time.
No matter.
Able fell to his knees, feeling the life draining
from him.
He wondered, when he awoke from the coffin
again, what the world would look like.
Sometimes it was days, sometimes weeks, months,
or even years.
As he fell forward, dying once again, he hoped
that he’d wake into a world with a warrior
or beast that could actually challenge him.
Maybe someday…
This was one of Able’s many lives, hundreds
of years before he was contained by the SCP
Foundation.
He’s perhaps the greatest warrior who ever
lived, died, and lived again.
He’s a man so individually deadly that not
only is he kept in a containment chamber under
the sea, surrounded by highly trained and
armed guards, he has his own localized on-site
nuclear weapon, ready to blow away and annihilate
him and his entire containment area if deemed
necessary.
He may not be a contagious anomalous pathogen
or a lethal memetic hazard or a giant beast
shooting world-destroying fireballs in every
direction, but if this one-man massacre was
left to his own devices, there’s no doubt
that he would methodically slaughter his way
through the human race until an XK-Class End
of the World Scenario was practically inevitable.
He was fueled by pure hatred and an almost
bottomless bloodlust.
He simply lived to fight and kill.
And not only did he have the will and the
skill to be a pure force of annihilation,
but his anomalous abilities also make him
perfectly tailored to the task.
He has massively enhanced physical strength,
speed, and durability, taking the kind of
damage that would kill several normal humans
to reliably put him down - Though even that
is only a temporary measure.
Able will always resurrect back into his black
sarcophagus to menace the SCP Foundation another
day.
It is also effectively impossible to disarm
Able, because he has the anomalous ability
to pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket dimensions at will, and his proficiency
with these weapons is unlike any warrior the
world has ever known, before or since.
During containment breaches, he’s regularly
killed scores of trained Foundation guards,
with both numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons.
Despite being a simple humanoid, he was taking
up a truly insane amount of containment resources.
Despite his violent tendencies, Able is still
a recognizable sentient human, albeit an extremely
deadly anomalous one.
This led some higher-ups at the Foundation
to come up with an interesting idea: What
if Able’s eternal rage could be harnessed?
What if they could use their resources to
reshape this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the Foundation’s cause?
After all, if he wanted worthy opponents,
what could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the Foundation faced on a daily
basis?
And as long as they kept the sarcophagus,
even if Able was killed in the line of duty,
he’d still be accounted for.
In many ways, if he could be trained and truly
brought to heel, there could be no better
asset to their coming struggles.
It was this logic, allowing anomalies to work
for the SCP Foundation in exchange for benefits,
that led to the creation of a new, groundbreaking
Mobile Task Force: MTF Omega-7, Pandora’s
Box.
This group became the SCP Foundation’s hail
mary pass.
For any particularly dangerous or potentially
deadly mission, they could send in Able, along
with a group of highly-trained Foundation
soldiers that even the ancient, blade-wielding
warrior held respect for.
While, like their namesake, Pandora’s Box,
it would all wind up in terrible tragedy,
to begin with, they achieved some of the highest
mission successful results of any Mobile Task
Force on the Foundation’s payroll.
No task was too challenging for them to swoop
in and crush it.
This was far from expected: Able, one of the
most violent SCPs they’d ever contained,
suddenly becoming a great
asset to their operations.
A vital tool in their quest to keep the anomalous
at bay.
He’d cleaved through legions of Chaos Insurgency
soldiers during breaches into their secure
sites.
He’d fought off the well-paid, well-trained,
and well-armed body guards of Marshall, Carter,
and Dark Ltd. during Foundation raids on their
clandestine operations.
He’d even gone toe to toe with some of the
deadliest anomalies in containment during
mass escapes.
It was hard to imagine how they’d ever lived
without him.
Of course, while Able was happier than he’d
been in years - in his element, in fact, as
a working warrior, given varied missions and
frequent opponents - there was still something
nagging at him.
His thoughts were hounded by his white whale:
The endless search for a truly worthy opponent,
someone or something that could really give
him a run for his money.
After millennia of leaving opponents dead
in his wake, nothing would bring him more
joy than meeting something that actually knocked
him on his ass.
A new bar somewhere above him to work towards.
Oh, what a glorious day that would be…
Eventually, the Foundation started to run
into a problem: They were running out of missions
to give Able.
After all, he wasn’t the kind of operative
you could just give any mission to: His potential
for collateral damage was truly staggering.
He’d neutralize the anomaly, then slaughter
everyone within a hundred-foot range, just
to work off some of the excess energy.
Like a hand grenade, he was powerful, but
dangerously imprecise.
If they ran out of high-priority missions,
what were they supposed to do?
Just put Able back in his box to gather dust
until something else rolled around?
He was getting antsy enough between missions
already…
That’s when an unexpected member of personnel
stepped forward: Dr. Jack Bright.
You see, Dr. Bright and Able had a history
and not an altogether pleasant one - Not that
anyone could really have a pleasant history
with Able.
Jack was only a junior researcher when he
had his run-in, carrying a seemingly worthless
medallion dubbed SCP-963 back to its containment
locker.
That was when a wall next to him exploded,
showering him with brick fragments and dust,
only to reveal Able standing behind the new
aperture.
Before young Dr. Bright even had a chance
to scream, Able had already cleaved through
him, leaving him in two distinct parts that
were both very much dead.
At least it seemed that way, until it was
revealed that Dr. Bright’s consciousness
had actually been eternally bonded with SCP-963,
giving him the gift and curse of immortality.
Since then, Dr. Bright had become increasingly
reckless in his conduct, perhaps hoping that
the next time he fades to black, the movie
that is his sad, strange life won’t just
start to roll again.
Of course, he hasn’t been lucky in that
regard yet.
Naturally, this has given Dr. Bright complex
feelings about his fellow anomalous Foundation
employee.
So when the call came around all the senior
researchers and site directors, asking if
there were any tasks that Able seemed fit
for, he had one very pressing suggestion.
After all, it wasn’t that long after Dr.
Bright had been forced into a cross test with
the intention of terminating SCP-682 - Which
had not only been a failure, but a generally
painful and exhausting experience.
Now, perhaps it would be Able’s turn to
take his lumps.
He happily put forth the suggestion, claiming
that surely the Foundation’s new sword-wielding
golden boy could give killing the Hard to
Destroy Reptile the old college try.
After all, even if Able was killed in the
process, he’d just come right back.
It was a situation where they really could
not lose, so why not take a chance?
What’s the worse that could happen?
The O5 Council found Dr. Bright’s pitch
extremely compelling.
He’d succeeded in every mission they’d
given him so far, so perhaps he could carry
that success into the herculean task of actually
terminating SCP-682.
One boundlessly bloodthirsty killer might
be the only thing truly capable of taking
out another of equal magnitude.
When Able was informed of this latest mission,
he got a scary glint in his eye.
They gave him warning after warning: The beast
is said to be unkillable, it can adapt to
anything, it’s killed scores of people and
survived the attacks of anomalies thought
to be flawless killers.
The more it was explained to him, the more
Able felt the tingling sensation deep within:
Was this it?
Had he now discovered the perfect opponent?
Something that would actually challenge him,
would actually put him through his paces?
Yes, yes, yes!
He accepted the mission without question.
Able would fight SCP-682 until his breath
was no longer.
In order to prepare for the match, SCP-682
was released into a secure
area: Rocky, desert-like
terrain, bordered on all sides by a Foundation
perimeter, hundreds of meters away on all
sides.
They thought it best for the showdown to happen
here.
After all, with combatants like Able and SCP-682,
it was bound to make a mess, one way or another.
Able strode with pronounced swagger onto the
battleground shortly afterwards, carrying
perhaps the most powerful sword he’d ever
summoned.
It was somewhere between a claymore and a
chainsaw, an unholy union that gave the resulting
weapon a degree of deranged badassery not
ever seen on the battlefields of planet earth
before.
Carrying this thing, Able felt like a King,
and he was about to slay the most ancient
and bestial of monsters.
As he approached 682 and took in the whole
of it, he could feel his heart pounding with
excitement in his chest.
It was a huge, reptilian nightmare.
He could see its scales hardening into a mighty
carapace as he approached.
Its huge, serrated fangs.
Its bulging, sinewy muscles and insane,
dagger-like
claws.
Oh yes, this would be the one.
The beast snarled at him as he approached.
He just smiled, puffed out his chest, and
said…
“I have heard tales of creatures like you.
Glorious beasts of scale and flesh, talon
and fang, a prowess in battle even greater
than the immense intellect hiding behind those
bestial eyes.
They said your kind once ruled the Earth from
enormous stockpiles of treasure, killing and
eating all who displeased you.
But you were knocked from your throne, one
by one, by the great warriors who walk this
world no longer, until there were no more,
and you became but mere myth.
Even I had thought you to be nothing but fairy
tales, but yet, here you stand before me,
a living dragon…”
In response to Able’s lofty speech, the
monster merely grumbled and chided him, claiming
he was little more than a pathetic SCP Foundation
lapdog, following orders and being manipulated.
It showed no respect for Able as a valued
enemy combatant - Merely another nuisance
thrown at it in a futile attempt to finish
its wretched and seemingly eternal life.
Able couldn’t take such insolence.
He leaped forwards, bringing down his mighty
chainsaw claymore, ready to cleave the beast
in two.
However, what he didn’t expect was the move
SCP-682 pulled next: Throwing its head up
against the blade of Able’s sword, shredding
away huge chunks of flesh and bone, and utterly
confusing Able in the process.
For the first time in a lifetime of intense
battles, Able found himself thinking, “What
the hell am I up against here?”
The force of 682’s headbutt threw Able off
balance, leaving his stomach briefly exposed.
But “briefly” was all SCP-682 needed.
It thundered its massive, stony fist into
Able’s gut, throwing him like a ragdoll
into a nearby rock with such a force that
it nearly shattered the rock behind him.
It was a force like he hadn’t felt in years.
He spat some bloody teeth and grinned.
This was just what the doctor ordered.
He issued a challenge to the beast in a long-dead
language, as it seized violently, regenerating,
growing, taking on the stony qualities of
the ground around it.
It looked like a vengeful living mountain.
A true behemoth of a beast.
In other words, challenge accepted.
Able pulled an obscenely giant mace from the
shadows of his cloak - The handle six feet
long, with a chaos of swirling blades and
spikes.
A perfect weapon for slaying a dragon like
this, he thought to himself.
The two charged at each other, full of power
and fury.
Able swung the mace, once again shattering
the creature’s head and flinging it back
across the battlefield with the sheer force
of its strike.
The decimated lizard clawed its way into the
ground, devouring the rocks and the earth,
integrating more matter to fuel its regeneration.
But it wasn’t long before Able was upon
it again, striking mercilessly, giving blows
as the monster gave brutal claw strikes in
return.
They were ripping each other’s bodies apart,
piece by piece, but Able felt so exhilarated
he could barely even notice.
It was the fight of his life - A battle against
a truly worthy opponent.
This was heaven.
Able leaped into the air and unleashed a volley
of deadly chakram down onto the beast, shredding
into its reinforced flesh.
As the force of gravity brought him down,
he pulled a mighty axe from his cloak, and
bellowed a warrior’s roar as he brought
it down, splattering into the nightmarish
body of SCP-682.
However, this did nothing to even slow the
beast down.
It flipped over, slashing Able with its claws.
When Able stumbled, it leaped on top of him,
unleashing devastating slashes and punches
onto the fallen warrior with the speed of
a machine gun firing.
When it raised its claw to deal the killing
blow, though, Able once again turned the tables.
He produced a giant pair of mechanical scissors
from thin air, and sliced off both of SCP-682’s
forelegs.
The beast descended with its mighty jaws to
devour Able, but he kicked up, with freakish
strength behind his bladed boot.
The sheer force of the kick flipped SCP-682
onto its back.
Now, it was Able’s turn to execute his opponent,
though on some level he thought it would be
an awful shame to lose such a terrific beast
from this world of cardboard.
Still, a battle is a battle, and this is how
they go.
He jumped onto 682 and went berserk, slashing
into it relentlessly with blade after blade,
pulling out a new one every time the old one
broke from his sheer ferocity.
He screamed in incoherent battle fury, tearing,
slicing, ripping, rending.
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
As Able stepped away to breathe, the beast
began to regenerate, releasing a shockwave
that started to warp reality around it.
But Able wouldn’t have this.
No, he would give this beast no quarter.
It was time to present the true pain he was
notorious for..
He pulled a long sword from his cloak and
charged, taking air and bringing it down towards
SCP-682’s head.
The beast, sensing the warrior’s presence,
opened its mouth, unleashing a chasm of horrifying
teeth within.
The two were on a fierce collision course.
As the jaws closed, Able descended.
Both roared in infinite rage and bloodlust.
Both combatants fell to
the ground, just twitching.
Oh, what a glorious, terrible day it had been.
Neither had died for good, but both would
remember this incredible battle forever.
When Able awoke once more in his dark stone
coffin, he did so with a smile.
What a battle!
What a fight!
What a truly honorable pursuit!
After so long, being bored and unfulfilled,
he’d found an opponent that got his blood
pumping once more.
His stomach grumbled.
A post-battle feast was in order.
Now, where did they put that magic pizza box…
You all remember the story.
One of the most epic, sprawling, action-packed
tales in the entire multi-verse: The saga
of Pietro Wilson and the SCP-5000 exclusion
suit.
He went through an unimaginable hell to reset
the universe and save the world from an SCP
Foundation that had seemingly lost its mind,
in an unprecedented, intentional mass containment
breach that had the stated goal of wiping
out the human race.
It was one of the most horrifying possible
timelines imaginable, and we should all be
thankful for Pietro’s struggle and sacrifice.
Or should we?
After all, there are two sides to every story,
each with its own perspective and insight.
One side of the coin was Pietro - A man willing
to do anything to return normalcy to the human
race.
On the other side was a familiar, yet wholly
unexpected face…
SCP-682.
In our original telling of the SCP-5000 odyssey,
you may have noticed passing mentions of SCP-682
here and there.
It was one of the thousands of anomalies unleashed
across the world to wreak terrible havoc on
all of us.
But what you may not have known is that SCP-682
was one of the few intelligent entities that
weren’t surprised by the sudden turn taken
by the SCP Foundation, or indeed the world
at large.
SCP-682 knew something like this was inevitable.
As soon as human beings found out about IT.
That’s right: IT.
The Entity behind all the pain and misery
of SCP-5000.
And today, thanks to the inner thoughts of
none other than SCP-682
itself, you will understand
what it’s all about, and why the SCP Foundation
took such severe action against it.
But in order to truly understand this, and
the role that SCP-682 plays in it, we need
to go back to the beginning - Two Foundation
projects with wildly different
research implications,
Project PNEUMA and Project DAMMERUNG.
The first involved using
cutting-edge technological
advancements to map out the human psychosphere
and understand the psychic web that connects
us all.
The latter was an attempt to explore what
happens after death, and perhaps even gain
some control over its processes.
But as is often the case when mankind dabbles
in arcane questions better left unexplored,
the SCP Foundation didn’t like the answers
they found.
The rotten fruit of Project DAMMERUNG was
SCP-2718, also known as “What Happens After
Death.”
If you’re already familiar with this one,
then there’s a good chance a chill just
went down your spine - It’s widely considered
one of the most disturbing anomalous discoveries
ever, and a member of the O5 Council who’d
already experienced it decided to submit himself
for eternal torture at the hands of SCP-106
- Just so he could avoid it.
According to SCP-2718, after death there is
no heaven, no hell, and no oblivion.
The human consciousness endures in the most
horrifying way possible: It remains bonded
to its decaying earthly body, feeling the
slow agony of rot for eternity.
Unable to speak, unable to move, unable to
scream, but fully aware as everything they
once were putrefies and withers away.
And cremation isn’t an escape here - It’s
worse.
Every molecule of ash your body is reduced
to will cry out in silence, echoing around
the empty halls of your fragmented soul forever.
With something this utterly horrifying, the
natural follow-up questions are: “Why does
this happen, and for the love of all that
is good and pure on this earth, is there any
way to stop it?”
This brings us to Project PNEUMA, the one
that’s even more closely associated with
the events of SCP-5000.
The Foundation’s attempts to map out the
human psychosphere resulted in a world-shattering
discovery: Something was living in there.
The Entity, the powerful nameless creature
we’ve been referring to as IT.
It lives in so many of our heads, watching,
waiting, and of course, feeding.
The main question here is…
On what?
Prior to the discovery that changed everything
in the world of SCP-5000, the only being that
truly knew was SCP-682 itself.
Melting away in its acid tank, bound by reinforced
restraints, hurting, bored, hating.
Imagine, for a second, what the life of SCP-682
is like.
It isn’t the most dangerous of the anomalies
out there - there are devourers of worlds
and Scarlet Kings more than happy to crush
our whole world in their claws - nor is it
the most sadistic.
A being like SCP-106 offers a far more painful
death than being quickly mauled, crushed,
or eaten by the Hard to Destroy Reptile.
And despite this, the Foundation expends countless
resources in trying to murder it on a constant
basis.
It has been burnt, melted, eaten alive, drowned,
slashed, beaten, dissected, suffocated, erased
from existence, set upon by nightmare creatures,
torn to shreds on an atomic level, and even
more terrible termination attempts than you
can possibly imagine.
We’ve made several videos on the subject,
and even we have barely scratched the surface
of the pain inflicted on SCP-682 by the SCP
Foundation.
Even in its default state, SCP-682 is constantly
submerged in hydrofluoric acid, eating away
at it forever.
Does that remind you of anything else we’ve
been talking about?
You might wonder how SCP-682 can withstand
this level of constant torture without completely
losing its mind.
To put it very simply, 682 takes a great deal
of satisfaction in knowing that what every
human has to contend with after death is far
worse than the tortures it is expected to
endure at the pathetic hands of these doomed
human fools.
It already knew what Project DAMMERUNG discovered.
It already knew what Project PNEUMA discovered.
It already knew about IT, the Entity.
It felt the constant suffering of the teeming
billions of dead in the world around it.
And it found it…
Disgusting.
An interesting choice of words, and a favorite
for SCP-682, but also for the captured SCP
Foundation Agent Samuel Ross during SCP-5000.
As we discussed briefly in our SCP-5000 coverage,
something happened that aligned the perspectives
of the SCP Foundation with that of the monstrous
reptile they take such pleasure in tormenting.
What on earth could cause the protectors of
humanity to suddenly change their tune like
this?
There are other little clues embedded in Pietro’s
terrifying SCP-5000 experience.
You may remember a strange and frightening
scene where a Foundation Field Commander went
down a row of Foundation soldiers, stabbing
each of them with a large combat knife, and
none of them reacted.
Until one did…
At which point, his comrades set upon him
like mad dogs and killed him, displaying an
uncharacteristic level of swift brutality.
And then there are the classified files from
the O5 Council and the Ethics Committee, led
by Chairman Odongo Tejani.
It goes without saying that the O5 Council
and the Ethics Committee don’t really see
eye to eye on anything, but the results of
Project PNEUMA changed that.
The following is a classified conversation
between a member of the O5 Council, namely
O5-1, and Chairman Tejani, trying to comprehend
the horror of their discovery:
My hands shake as I hold the document.
"This is confirmed?"
He nods.
"We got the report from PNEUMA staff yesterday.
It's everyone."
"Even us?"
"Even us, Tejani.
To think I'd find myself agreeing with that
damn lizard…"
"What do we do?"
"You know what we have to do.
We'll have to disseminate a cure, I think,
among personnel before we get things underway.
It'll try to stop us otherwise."
"God help us, One."
"Don't be like that, Tejani.
That's IT talking."
And one more incredibly telling quote from
a member of the SCP Foundation, picked up
by Pietro Wilson during SCP-5000:
“Once you realize you're not supposed to
feel pain, there's nothing to be afraid of
anymore.”
Is it all coming together now?
While each participant here only has a part
of the puzzle, between us all, we can see
the full picture: The Entity, IT, has inhabited
the human psychosphere for as long as we’ve
existed.
It’s a kind of metaphysical parasite, attached
to the entire human race.
And what it feeds on seems to be the after
effects of pain.
And like all efficient parasites, like a tapeworm
that induces hunger in its victims so that
it can have more food delivered unto itself,
the Entity cleverly perpetuates its own food
source.
That’s right - IT is the very cause of all
pain.
Humanity was never actually meant to feel
it.
It’s a lie we’ve told ourselves.
Well, not quite something we told ourselves,
but something IT told us.
It induced pain and tricked us all into believing
that it was a natural component of our existence.
All the while, it fed on us.
Sustained itself on the suffering that it
had seeded within our hearts and souls.
The Foundation discovered this and was horrified.
But of course, the pain it caused for the
living was only part of the equation.
Through the revelations of Project DAMMERUNG
- another thing that SCP-682 was able to know
intuitively - we can complete this puzzle
and find the terrible truth.
That truth being that IT is not only behind
the suffering we experience in life, but SCP-2718,
the even greater suffering we experience in
death.
For millennia, it has groomed humanity into
a perfect, all you can eat buffet of dismal
pain and suffering.
And until recently, they’d been so blissfully
ignorant of the horrible fate that awaited
them on the other side.
The Foundation saw only one solution to this
problem, but it certainly wasn’t a nice
one.
In order to save themselves and all of humanity
from a truly wretched eternity, they’d need
to distribute a cure among themselves - the
memetic keyphrase “Harden Your Hearts”
- and then go about exterminating every human
being still infected by IT.
Only that would presumably purge the monster
from the psychosphere forever, and grant humanity
both painless lives and restful deaths.
It was a horrible thing done for the best
of reasons.
The Cured Foundation Personnel started to
notice the horrible background noise of suffering
all around them.
They now understood how the reptile felt.
To call all of this disgusting would be a
grave understatement.
If anything could help them execute this plan
of mass mercy killing, it would be SCP-682
- A scaly savior in disguise all along.
SCP-682 was surprised to see the day arrive.
Alarms went off across the containment site.
His acid tank was drained, his restraints
unlocked.
A group of unarmed, unprotected researchers
entered the room.
He saw into their eyes: They’d changed.
They were free.
And for the first time in decades, he was
free, too.
They explained to him that they’d become
acquainted with his old enemy, the Entity,
IT.
They understood his malice, his disdain.
For once, they were suddenly joined in a shared
goal: They needed to kill them all.
They needed to purge the Entity from the
psychosphere
forever.
In the words of the Foundation researchers,
they would need to exterminate everyone who
was infected, and SCP-682 would need to help.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile, relishing the
opportunity, replied, “I will do my part.”
And for a brief window of glorious time, it
was free, with no threat of recapture.
It rampaged through the world,
gleefully slaughtering
scores of people.
It was in its element, taking part in the
mass extermination of the infected.
Every dead body added to the pile was another
blow struck against IT.
Soon enough, the world would be disgusting
no longer.
But of course, that’s not how this story
ended.
IT had a trump card: Pietro Wilson.
It guided him all the way, dragging him from
nightmare to nightmare, until he was eventually
able to reset the world and erase the discovery
made by Project PNEUMA.
The slate was wiped fully clean, and because
of it, we’re forever ignorant of the terrible
fate awaiting us after death, and the monster
lurking in our psychosphere that feeds off
of every morsel of suffering.
You can thank Pietro Wilson for that nasty
little gift.
Only one entity truly remembered what had
happened: SCP-682, of course.
They had their chance to save themselves,
and they ruined it.
So close, yet so far.
From that day onward, SCP-682 found the Foundation
not only disgusting, but disappointing.
The SCP Foundation has encountered its fair
share of incredibly tough adversaries and
fearsome monsters, but none are as formidable
- or at least, as durable - as SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile.
We’ve talked about this behemoth before
in a number of mind-boggling videos, and all
of the increasingly desperate lengths the
Foundation has gone to in order to terminate
it.
We’ve gotten so desperate to put this thing
to rest that we’ve even reached out to all
of you for suggestions on the matter.
Sadly, they’ve thrown 682 together with
some of the most destructive anomalies in
Foundation custody, and it’s slithered out
of seemingly inescapable danger every time.
So much so that we’ve noticed certain researchers
on the 682 case have started drinking a little
more heavily as of late…
Sometimes the threats didn’t leave so much
as a dent in the monster’s scales, sometimes
the other creature ran screaming at the sight
of it, and sometimes 682 mutated and twisted
its form in ways that were shocking even to
a Foundation research team that has seen just
about all there is to see.
After all, 682’s truly insane adaptability
has always been its number one power, and
the key to its infuriating
death-defying abilities.
And these are some of SCP-682’s craziest
mutations.
During one round of tests, SCP-682 was released
into an enclosure with SCP-272, a nail that
traps any living thing in place when it is
dropped onto the organism’s shadow.
682 was surrounded by 30 two-thousand-watt
stadium lights, one of which was switched
on.
As soon as it entered the enclosure, a D-Class
dropped the nail onto the creature’s shadow.
It was promptly pinned in place, and all thirty
lights were switched on and off in random
patterns, causing the reptile to be hurled
around the room at devastating speeds.
After nearly an hour of this, about 95 percent
of the monster’s skin had been worn down,
sixty-three of its teeth had been broken from
its jaw, and its eyeballs had come loose from
their sockets.
At this point, something truly bizarre happened.
The exposed tissue beneath 682’s top layer
of skin, previously bloody and dark red, began
to give off a bright white light.
The subdermal tissue grew steadily brighter
and brighter until it eclipsed the glow from
the stadium lights, and removed any shadows
cast along the floor.
It collapsed on the ground and continued giving
off violently bright light
for the next forty-eight
hours, so bright that it caused permanent
retinal damage to all personnel in the room.
Hell of a light show, but this next mutation
proves just how hard it is to lick SCP-682
- Especially when it develops the tools to
start licking back.
SCP-743 is a chocolate fountain that exhibits
some carnivorous qualities.
When it is near a living organism, especially
if it consumes the fountain’s delicious
chocolate, it produces swarms of ant-like
monsters that devour the organism piece by
piece, carrying the bits into the fountain
until nothing is left.
The research team was curious
about the possibilities
of introducing 743 to 682, so it was transported
to the reptile’s testing chamber.
Within a few minutes, chocolate began to flow
from the fountain.
682 was curious and began to drink from it.
It may hate almost everything, but even 682
can’t resist chocolate.
It drank greedily, for several minutes, until
the fountain began releasing the ants.
Within moments, 682 was covered in ants and,
in spite of its best efforts to fight off
the swarm, it was completely covered and rendered
immobile.
The ants made quick work of the massive creature,
and after several minutes it had been stripped
down to less than 80 percent of its original
mass.
It seemed as if this might truly be it for
the beast, but then…it opened its mouth.
It unfurled its tongue, now over 5 meters
long and sticky, comparable to an enlarged
version of an anteater’s tongue.
It began lapping up the ants, thousands at
a time picked up by its mutated tongue.
As it devoured the ants, more poured out of
the fountain, slicing off pieces of 682’S
flesh with their pincers and carrying them
back to the fountain.
They reached a symbiotic pace, feeding on
each other in equal measure for hours until
testing was terminated.
That was a sticky situation.
But trust me, this next crazy mutation will
really blow you away.
SCP-3108, also known as “the Nerfing gun,”
is an altered toy gun that turns anything
it hits into an inferior version of itself.
When the gun was fired at a tissue sample
taken from SCP-682, the sample turned into
a piece of tissue from a giant leaf-tailed
gecko.
Hoping to carry this over and turn 682 into
a harmless animal, a D-class officer was sent
into the containment chamber to fire the gun
at the entity.
Once it was hit with the foam dart, it began
to transform.
Unfortunately, instead of becoming a simple
gecko, it began to mutate.
It grew larger, its muscles bulging noticeably
beneath its scaly skin.
Its teeth grew longer, sharper, its tongue
sprouting teeth of its own.
It opened its mouth to roar, and it appeared
that the teeth, long curved fangs with a deadly
tip, went all the way back down the beast’s
throat.
Security officers were deployed to temporarily
neutralize the monster, but found that it
was even more powerful than before.
Not only was it bigger, but it had developed
a new ability.
When threatened, it would begin to vibrate
at a high rate, grinding its teeth together,
and it would explode in a burst of fire and
meaty chunks.
Fangs flew in every direction like shrapnel,
tearing into personnel and lodging in their
skin.
This is an impressive move, but it seems like
a one-time trick, right?
Wrong.
The bits and pieces, no matter how tiny or
how flattened to mush, would crawl back together
and form the creature all over again.
It was able to escape containment like this,
killing an untold number of personnel before
it was temporarily incapacitated and returned
to its containment.
Mutating back into life from a self-induced
explosion is pretty crazy, but surely you
can’t mutate back from nothing at all, right?
Right!?
Oh boy, I don’t like that look you’re
giving me…
SCP-3930 is a void located near Usinsk, Russia,
within which nothing exists.
Once something has passed within its border,
it ceases to be, though outside observers
will be able to perceive them for a small
time after.
SCP-682 was brought to 3930, and it walked
inside.
Once there, it ceased existing.
However, even though 682 no longer existed,
Foundation personnel looking at the void could
still see the beast.
Whenever they viewed it, a strong image appeared
in the brain of the person looking, and it
had the exact appearance of SCP-682.
Somehow, even when it didn’t exist, 682
was able to attack and kill various personnel.
These people did not die from physical damage,
but from their brain function
suddenly, inexplicably
stopping.
The reptile defied the rules of the void,
somehow causing real destruction even though
it was not real.
Fifteen hours later, 682 was found in its
containment chamber as if nothing had happened
at all.
It had been snuffed out of existence and had
mutated its way back into reality, with no
explanation.
Well, that was existentially terrifying.
Thank 343 that at least there’s only one
of these things.
Oh no…
SCP-3207 is a highly efficient mobile war
machine, outfitted with cannons capable of
firing blasts that can vaporize organic matter
on contact.
This seems like a good match for something
supposedly indestructible. 3207 was fired
at 682 several times, appearing to destroy
it completely except for a smudge on the floor
of the chamber.
The reptile was gone for a duration of six
hours before something strange began to happen.
Globs of tissue began to clump together, forming
five separate piles.
They pulled closer and
closer together, compressing
into five reptilian creatures.
They writhed around, getting used to their
new legs and teeth, snapping their jaws at
any living thing in sight.
Overwhelming and surprising
the security personnel,
who had been lulled into a false sense of
security by the apparent defeat of 682, the
five smaller versions of the entity were able
to escape containment.
Once they had made it into the hallway, they
began to clamber over each other, their scales
shifting, eyeballs squeezing together and
fusing into one eye, skin stretching like
hot rubber over unnaturally bendy bone.
As the shocked security personnel watched,
the five lizards melted into one, becoming
a full-sized version of SCP-682 that was good
as new.
They were able to contain it after a great
deal of effort, but one of the researchers
requested a note be added to the research
notes for the day, and applied going forward:
DO NOT EXPLODE.
Okay, so the big lizard is a constant threat.
Got it.
Still, wouldn’t it be nice if 682 could
make itself a little smaller?
I can’t imagine anything bad coming from
that…
SCP-1056 is an anomalous kitchen timer capable
of changing the size of living objects.
The Foundation wanted to see how long it would
take 682 to return to its original size after
being shrunk.
So, they built a testing chamber connected
to 1056’s dial, and released 682 inside,
sealing the door behind it.
The dial was set to 0.25, and the activation
button was pressed.
682 thrashed around, bellowing as parts of
its body expanded and contracted at random.
Then, with no warning, it disappeared.
D-class personnel were deployed to investigate
the chamber, but it seemed to be completely
gone.
There was no sign of it.
It’s pretty hard to lose a giant lizard,
so naturally, they were all a bit perplexed.
The chamber was kept sealed, under the assumption
that 682 had to still be inside somewhere.
Sometime later, a security officer spotted
682 outside of Site-19, returned to its original
size.
Somehow, during the test, 682 used the effects
of 1056 to strengthen its ability to change
its own size.
It adapted and shrank to a size so small that
no one watching could even see it anymore,
and it slipped out through the sealed door.
It was even temporarily able to change the
size of other objects around it, shrinking
weapons used to contain down until they were
useless.
Okay, so SCP-682 is pretty cool under pressure.
But what if we made it a whole lot colder?
Most of the testing on 682 is done with other
anomalies, however, sometimes the Foundation
likes to simplify a bit.
Dr. Carlson suggested they try something a
bit more basic: liquid nitrogen.
One ton of liquid nitrogen was poured onto
SCP-682 from above.
As it tends to do, the liquid nitrogen promptly
froze the beast solid.
It remained stuck in place for about 10 minutes,
until it began to melt the frozen cast around
it.
Its core body temperature seemed to skyrocket,
producing intense heat that fully thawed it
in three minutes.
It didn’t stop there, though.
Its temperature continued to increase, growing
hotter and hotter as if to deliberately punish
the research staff for even attempting to
freeze it.
It became so hot that the research staff had
to leave the room.
An attending doctor’s pen melted, the plastic
burning his hands.
Steam rose off the sides of its body, fogging
up the windows of the room.
The test was abandoned after the sides of
the containment chamber began to melt, and
they worried the creature would be able to
breach containment.
Once it was left alone, 682 cooled back down
to its usual temperature.
Maybe we should see what happens if we try
a slightly greener method of destruction…
682 was exposed to SCP-166, a young nature
spirit that can cause organic matter in her
vicinity to decompose.
As soon as 166 was released into its chamber,
682 began to run toward her even as its body
began to melt.
As it got closer, it began to decay and fall
apart more rapidly, pieces of its body softening
and sloughing off in chunks.
By the time it reached 166, it had melted
down into the shape of a patch of grass covered
with colorful wildflowers.
Fifteen minutes later, it began to regenerate
itself as it usually does, its body reconstituting
at the same rate it was melting.
The regeneration process began to speed up,
going faster and faster until it surpassed
the rate of melting.
A piece of the monster would soften and flop
to the ground, but by the time it landed a
patch of regrowth had already replaced it.
It eventually beat the melting process and
regenerated to its original form, with one
difference: it had a sprinkling of flowers
and mushrooms on its back, resembling a forest
clearing.
It was almost pretty, even on top of such
a foul creature, until a full-sized tree suddenly
burst out of its back, shooting up to a height
of ten feet and puncturing the roof of its
containment chamber.
Hello again, dear viewers.
You’ve caught me during my break.
What?
Even researchers at the SCP Foundation need
a little downtime now and then.
And considering they revoked
my playtime privileges
with The Living Lego and the Nerfing Gun after
the unfortunate incident in the Site-19 Break
Room, I’ve been downgraded to keeping myself
occupied with this little rubber ball.
“I have a ball.
Perhaps you'd like to bounce it,” they said.
Seems innocent enough, doesn’t it?
Oh, have you learned nothing?
Almost any object, even something as innocuous
as a Teddy Bear or a plastic paddling pool,
can hide secrets.
Sure, any avid basketball fan will happily
tell you that ball is life.
But sometimes, when you’re dealing with
anomalies, a ball can also… be death.
Such is the case of SCP-018, also known as
The Super Ball.
An anomaly so powerful that the Foundation
has even used it to help recontain SCP-682
during a breach.
To the untrained observer, it really isn’t
much to look at.
A small, red rubber ball, about six centimeters
in diameter, produced by the Wham-O company
in 1969.
Yeah, we were as surprised as you to find
out that good ol’ Dr. Wondertainment had
nothing to do with this little number.
You might also be surprised by just how extensive
the containment procedures are for SCP-018
- After all, it’s rare that a competently
non-sentient anomaly makes its way into the
Euclid class.
This little rubber ball is
kept in a specially-made
titanium-alloy metal restraint, submerged
in a dense polyethylene holding tank, filled
with a special endothermic compound that draws
the kinetic energy out of its surroundings.
Anyone entering the chamber needs to wear
a unique kind of reinforced plate armor, and
if SCP-018 ever manages to escape its containment
tank, nearby personnel are advised to treat
it as they would an active shooter situation.
Lock yourself in a nearby room, duck down
below any cover you can find, and wait for
armed containment units to show up and take
control of the situation.
At this point, you probably have a lot of
questions, chief among them being: Why is
this children’s toy being given more security
precautions than most serial killers?
The ball was first discovered when a cleaning
and disposal company was hired to empty out
an old Wham-O warehouse of
some defunct merchandise.
One of the movers, Roy Fischler, embraced
his inner child when he saw a red, rubber
ball sitting among all the dusty boxes of
expired silly putty and broken remote control
robots.
He thought to himself, “what’s the harm
in having a little fun here?
It’s all going into the trash anyway.”
This would prove to be a terrible mistake
for all involved.
The anomalous property of SCP-018 is the fact
that it’s able to bounce at 200% efficiency
every time it’s bounced, increasing at an
exponential rate with each bounce unless it’s
stopped by some equivalent force.
So when Roy decided to toss that little red
ball onto the ground, he’d unleashed a destructive
force into that warehouse that was more powerful
than he ever could have imagined.
With every bounce, the ball increased its
height and speed, ricocheting across the floor,
walls, and ceiling like a bullet run amok.
And it was only just getting started.
The workers hit the deck as the item that
would later be dubbed SCP-018 decided to put
the “ball” in “ballistic.”
It smashed light fixtures.
Knocked over piles of boxes.
Smashed through forklifts.
When one worker tried to catch it, it left
a red-hot, ball-shaped hole in the middle
of his palm.
It wasn’t long before the ball had built
up such speed that the warehouse could no
longer contain it.
It blasted out of the wall and rocketed into
the nearby city, ready to cause more abject
chaos wherever it went.
Windows were shattered.
Street lights were annihilated.
Cars crashed.
Thankfully, no humans were killed by the rampaging
rubber menace, but in total five people were
injured - And one unfortunate pigeon was utterly
obliterated on impact.
It went on for several days, with the ball
reaching over 100 kilometers per hour at several
points, before finally coming to rest at a
nearby lake.
At which point, it was retrieved by Foundation
personnel.
There were two silver linings to this incredibly
strange anomalous incident: The first was,
as previously alluded to, nobody actually
died.
The second was that, due to the incredible
speeds at which SCP-018 moved, none of the
civilian witnesses had any idea what they’d
just encountered.
As far as anomalous discoveries go, this was
pretty much as close to a win as you can get.
But for one ambitious researcher, it was far
more than just a pleasingly non-violent initial
containment story - It was a doorway to improving
the Foundation’s technology as a whole.
Meet Dr. Brian Karella.
He’s what you might call a maverick, a blue
sky thinker, always on his grind.
The cornerstone of Dr. Karella’s philosophy
was that the Foundation should be making more
active use of its benign anomalies to help
track down and contain their more ornery foes.
While everyone else around him seemed to only
see a little rubber nuisance that was better
locked away, Dr. Karella saw the immense potential
in SCP-018.
Namely, in providing a vital enhancement to
another piece of Foundation technology: The
SCP-A5 Armor.
It goes without saying that working for the
SCP Foundation is an incredibly dangerous
job, especially if you’re part of one of
the Foundation’s myriad mobile task forces.
The hunt for anomalies can lead to all kinds
of strange and inhospitable terrains.
Before it was contained, SCP-096 was famously
captured on an icy, frozen tundra on top of
a bleak mountain.
Because of incidents like this, the Foundation
had first invested money in the SCP-A5 Tactical
Armor Suit.
Think of them like the Foundation’s answer
to the Iron Man suit.
However, when dressed in several hundred pounds
of reinforced metal, something important suffers
along the way: Mobility.
It isn’t exactly easy to lug all that equipment
around.
And when an anomaly is heading for the hills
at high speeds, being well-defended doesn’t
count for much if you’re already ten miles
behind the target in pursuit.
This, in Dr. Karella’s mind, was exactly
where SCP-018 came into play.
If that little red ball was built into the
foot of an SCP-A5 Armor suit, it could be
used to bounce the operative wearing it to
tremendous heights.
This would allow them to not only give chance
against fast-moving anomalies but also cover
difficult terrain and even scale great heights
in a mere instant.
But it wasn’t just an increase to mobility
that SCP-018 integration offered to the SCP-A5
suit.
Picture this: With SCP-108 fused to the sole
of the suit’s reinforced metal foot, lending
it 200% bouncing efficiency, it could unleash
a deadly, concrete-shattering kick.
The kind of thing that would leave you singing
in falsetto for the rest of your life if you
were lucky enough to survive it, if you know
what I mean.
To Dr. Karella, it was a match made in heaven.
It could increase both the mobility and combat
effectiveness of the suits by a considerable
margin.
And seeing as SCP-018 literally didn’t have
a mind of its own, there’s no way it could
suddenly go rogue during a mission and compromise
everything - just as Able had during his stint
as a Mobile Task Force operator before they
ran out of targets for him and he started
slaughtering his own comrades.
Dr. Karella was so confident in the efficacy
of this idea, he contacted the O5 Council
personally to request approval for this little
pet project.
This approval was granted, on a purely
experimental
basis.
The technology would have to prove itself
before being put into common use.
It wasn’t exactly what Karella wanted to
hear, but it was a step in the right direction.
He just needed the perfect opportunity to
put them to the test.
And then it came: SCP-682, the Infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile, breached containment.
It’d somehow adapted a cloaking ability
and escaped further from the site it was being
held at than ever before.
The next time it was spotted was over two
weeks later, causing pandemonium in the Amazon
Rainforest, devouring tribesmen and wreaking
havoc on the local ecosystem.
They needed to get on the scene fast and put
that monster down before the damage it caused
was irreparable, and news of the Beast in
the Amazon leaked out into the local area.
And thankfully, Dr. Karella had just the tool
for the job.
Field Agent Hammersmith was fitted with an
SCP-A5 suit, complete with the SCP-018 enhancement
in his dominant right leg.
He was dispatched, and immediately, the augmented
suit began to show its efficacy.
Agent Hammersmith bounded above the treeline
at incredible speeds, using the HUD in the
suit’s mask to track the heat signature
of SCP-682 moving among the trees below him.
He’d been able to bind a tracking collar
to the beast’s neck during an earlier engagement,
but now the true battle was on.
His heart was pounding, adrenaline coursing
through his veins, but he’d been ensured
that even 682 would have a hard time tearing
through his suit’s armor.
A commander directing him through an earpiece
told him now was the time to engage, before
682 detected his presence and began developing
countermeasures.
Dr. Karella was watching a live feed from
the control room, confident that his 018-augmented
suit would do the job.
Following his orders to the letter, Hammersmith
descended down onto 682 from above.
However, before he could make contact, the
reptile swiped him with its tail, sending
his body sailing into a nearby tree.
However, the suit stood firm.
He felt the impact, but the actual damage
was minimal.
Now, it was time for him to face off against
the beast, one on one.
He didn’t have time to be afraid.
As the beast descended upon him, fangs bared,
he gave it a swift kick to the bottom jaw,
tearing off half of its face.
But anyone who knows SCP-682 would tell you
that simply removing its bottom jaw wouldn’t
even slow 682 down.
It was relentless, attacking Hammersmith with
its fangs and jaws.
It tore deep ruts into the suit’s metal,
but the suit was still managing to keep its
occupant safe.
Then Hammersmith struck back.
Kick after kick, augmented by the 200% power
of the Super Ball, sliced huge chunks from
the reptile’s body.
He kicked in its chest, kicked off limbs,
and with a final mighty kick, even managed
to bisect the beast in the middle.
Of course, even that wouldn’t keep it down
for long, but with the hum of evacuation and
containment helicopters rapidly approaching,
Hammersmith breathed a sigh of relief.
Back in the control room, everyone celebrated
- Dr. Karella most of all, vindicated in his
belief that SCP-018 could save the day.
And then Agent Hammersmith, without even thinking,
rested his right foot on the floor just that
little bit too firmly.
The sudden bounce sent Hammersmith a mile
into the air.
His Foundation-trained composure evaporated;
all he could do was scream as he blasted up
into the clouds, then began to plummet.
Back in the control room, everyone could see
a live feed of Agent Hammersmith hurtling
into a nearby lake and landing with an epic
splash.
While the regenerating remains of SCP-682
were contained and brought back to the nearest
containment site, another team was sent in
to retrieve the heavily injured Agent Hammersmith.
His medical examination afterward revealed
he’d suffered two broken legs, seven broken
ribs, a missing arm, and a skull fracture.
If he hadn’t been wearing the suit, his
mangled remains probably would have been devoured
by the local piranhas by now.
But despite that minor hiccup in the plan,
Dr. Karella was still delighted with the results,
and immensely proud of the little red ball
that could.
In his closing remarks on the incident, he
appended a final note to the SCP-018 file,
reading:
“Don't worry, it's fixed.
But, I have some more ideas.
If I can be granted the use of some water
from SCP-006, as well as some other SCPs,
I can deliver you a set of SCP-A5 armor and
an agent that can capture any, if not all,
rogue or unattained SCPs.
All I'm waiting on is your approval.”
A beloved mentally unstable, masked vigilante
once said, “I’m not trapped in here with
you, you’re trapped in here with me!”
And this exact sentiment was shared by SPCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, as it traversed
the almost limitless, liminal hell known as
The Backrooms.
It’d been little more than a standard “chase
and secure” mission for the Mobile Task
Forces pursuing SCP-682 after its latest deadly
containment breach, until the vicious lizard
made its way into an abandoned warehouse and
no clipped its way into a new reality.
As the SCP Foundation are still desperately
searching for the missing beast back in our
native reality, 682 has been discovering whole
new vistas of violence.
First, it found itself in the endless yellow
halls of Level Zero, where if the madness
doesn’t get you, the starvation and thirst
will - Well, unless you’re an anomalous
reptilian abomination that can seemingly adapt
to any situation.
Once 682 escaped this gaudy purgatory, it
found its way into Level One, an endless warehouse
full of equal parts monsters and hapless human
settlers - all of whom it decimated in a single
bloody afternoon.
Then, onto Level Two, the Pipe Rooms, where
it faced a bevy of beasts that it eagerly
put into the ground.
And that brings us up to now - And, by extension,
onto Level Three.
SCP-682 spilled out into another section of
long, industrial hallways.
It didn’t know how it had gotten in, and
honestly, it didn’t really care at this
point.
All it needed to do was keep moving forward
and killing as it pleased, and it seemed there
were plenty of creatures down here to kill.
That being said, this level had a certain
energy to it.
And we mean that literally: 682’s incredibly
sensitive…
Well, senses, allowed it to detect an incredibly
powerful electrical field emanating from this
level.
And from the sounds of machines humming all
around it, traveling down great bundles of
wires and pipes bound to the walls, it knew
that this level must have been attached to
a generator of truly incredible size.
It charged forward, weaving around the different
hallways at freakish speeds, searching for
the next thing it could blast into oblivion.
And thankfully, it was able to find its first
target soon enough.
A nest of creatures known as Death Moths.
These were huge, fluttering moths of freakish
size, congregating around a glowing electrical
outlet.
Intriguing.
SCP-682 decided to approach and introduce
itself - After all, they looked like pretty
easy prey.
682 would regret this oversight.
While the male Death Moths are pretty much
harmless, the female Death Moths have an extremely
potent defense mechanism.
As SCP-682 approached, the creatures began
swarming and spraying acid onto its reptilian
flesh.
This was painful and irritating for 682, of
course, but if any entity on earth is pretty
accustomed to dealing with large quantities
of powerful acid by now, it’s SCP-682.
Its skin quickly healed from the acidic onslaught
and it developed a powerful counteradaptation:
A long, sticky, frog-like tongue, which it
used to devour the nest full of Death Moths
and move along to its next target.
It continued exploring Level 3.
A number of hallways were marked off with
metal bars - another very familiar sight for
SCP-682 - so, for simplicity’s sake, it
just kept itself to the unobstructed paths.
That’s where it soon ran into another lifeform,
standing around like a sitting duck in one
of the level’s many anonymous hallways.
It was just another human, in a similar outfit
to all those “Major Explorer Group” weaklings
it had destroyed earlier.
Strangely, even when SCP-682 entered the hallway
with it, it didn’t seem to react properly.
It just vacantly stared off into space, stumbling
around awkwardly.
682, bemused, whipped this random, disoriented
stranger in the chest with its tail, sending
him sailing into the nearby wall.
It was at this point that something strange
happened: The force of the strike caused the
man’s clothes, and also skin, to disintegrate,
leaving something entirely different underneath.
SCP-682 had no idea what was going on, but
it knew that it hated it.
This was its first encounter with a creature
known as a Skin Stealer.
It would be natural for a human being to be
terrified of an abomination like this.
An apex predator like 682, on the other hand?
It barely even found the Skin Stealer interesting.
With a single stomp from its clawed, reptilian
foot, the creature was very, very dead, and
SCP-682 continued its journey through the
bowels of Level 3.
It found itself drawn to whatever the source
of all the energy was, if it even had one
single source.
It was almost as though the entire level was
one giant generator, powering the rest of
the Backrooms.
And if there was electricity, perhaps there
were other humans in here to kill…
SCP-682 liked that idea very much indeed.
However, while making its way down a slightly
wider hallway - one that it had previously
believed was completely uninhabited - it was
suddenly ambushed by a group of mysterious
attackers.
A number of tall, grey creatures with long,
clawing arms and unclear facial features stepped
away from the wall.
These entities are known as the Dullers, ambush
predators native to the Backrooms.
They normally run away from
threats, but considering
the number of them congregated in the hall
around SCP-682, perhaps they felt a little
more confident about taking down their prey
in a group.
But they’d made a grave calculation: It
wouldn’t matter whether there was one Duller
or a thousand Dullers.
In the battle between them and SCP-682, they
would always, always, always be the prey.
But lucky for them, while they weren’t aware
of this immutable fact yet, SCP-682 was more
than happy to give them a first-hand education.
While the Dullers tried their best to claw
into 682’s thick, leathery hide, the creature
decided to employ a new ability it had stolen
from the female Death Moths.
Several new glands developed all over 682’s
body, each of which produced a fine mist of
highly concentrated acid.
Soon enough, the Dullers were howling in pain,
and melting away into dull, grey puddles on
the ground, never to reconstitute again.
That’s what you get for trying to climb
up the food chain, folks.
It never ends well.
Unless you’re 682, that is.
After disposing of the Dullers - which, in
682’s own humble opinion had more than earned
that title by indeed being extremely dull
- it decided to continue its search for some
of the power sources on this level.
Perhaps it could harness this ability for
its own benefit.
But it was interrupted by what is, frankly,
one of the grossesst enemies in all of the
Backrooms: The Bursters.
And if even hearing that name made you feel
a little sick, then you’re correctly primed
for what you’re about to encounter.
They’re humanoid creatures that walk around
on all fours, with its back legs grotesquely
stretched out into the shape of a dog’s
hind legs.
But that’s nothing compared to a Burster’s
truly diabolical backne.
All over the creature’s back, you can see
huge, callused cysts that contain a potent
and noxious acid.
Sure, the acid is only about as dangerous
as the stuff produced by female Death Moths,
but in our humble opinion, the method of acid
delivery is far more repulsive, and that makes
Bursters less desirable to encounter.
A small group of them skittered out of the
darkness towards SCP-682.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile also found them
disgusting - though now that we think about
it, SCP-682 thinks all forms
of life are disgusting,
so we suppose it’s all relative.
However, when they began to burst their backs
and coat 682 in their horrible pus, they perhaps
earned the rarely-given label of “extra
disgusting” from this living embodiment
of reptilian hate.
682 quickly retaliated by clawing the horrid
creatures to death, which I think we can all
agree is a good and well-deserved ending for
the vile little beasts.
We would have done the same thing.
The next enemies that 682 encountered weren’t
nightmarish creatures, but in fact, were human
beings stationed in the Major Explorer Group’s
Base Gamma, the third most important base
in all of the Backrooms.
They were on high alert after losing contact
with Base Alpha several days before - Having
no idea that everyone at that base had been
slaughtered by SCP-682, a fate that, if they
weren’t tremendously lucky, they would soon
share.
But they had a little more than luck on their
side this time…
SCP-682 sighted the base on the end of a long
hallway.
There was even a person standing at the other
end of the hall, seemingly blissfully unaware
of the encroaching presence of one of the
SCP Foundation’s most dangerous and formidable
captives. 682 loved killing humans most of
all - They weren’t just dumb animals, they
had the intellectual capacity to actually
appreciate the life that was being ripped
away from them, and it made the whole act
even more pleasurable for SCP-682.
It set its sights on the ignorant Major Explorer
Group member leaning against the distant wall,
and decided to charge for him, claws extended
and fangs bared.
This would be such easy prey.
Until the moment when someone in the distance
yelled, “NOW!”, and the seemingly defenseless
human turned around and pulled a level on
the wall.
Suddenly, the whole hallway was electrified,
sending millions of volts coursing through
SCP-682’s writhing body.
This whole thing had been an elaborate trap!
The humans at Base Gamma hadn’t survived
this long in the Backrooms by being stupid.
The more technically savvy members had rewired
some of the hallways to channel the immense
energy of the generators, and fry any unfortunate
entities that tried to use these hallways
to break into Base Gamma.
There was one big problem, though: SCP-682
wasn’t just any unfortunate entity.
While it initially looked like the electrcity
might fry the beast, it gradually began channeling
the electricity into its own body, and developing
the capacity to regift this electricity to
the people who so kindly provided it.
SCP-682, now a crackling conduit of electrcity,
leaped from the shocking hallway and into
Base Gamma.
Soon enough, it had fatally electrocuted all
300 members of the Major Explorer Group posted
in Base Gamma, and returned to its baseline
state.
Level 3 had grown tiresome now - It seemed
there were no more exciting new creatures
to massacre.
As a result, 682 slid into a nearby elevator,
and went down, where a new level awaited.
This was how SCP-682 got to Level 4.
And Level 4 was not what the Hard to Destroy
Reptile expected.
In contrast to the industrial nightmare of
the previous few levels, Level 4 was like
a limitless office block with all the furniture
ripped out.
While for some this might represent the crushing,
existential banality of office life, and how
the wheels of capitalism inevitably work us
to death, SCP-682 had never worked in an office
before, so it didn’t really have the proper
cultural reference points to appreciate this
more abstract kind of fear.
It wanted monsters to kill!
682 spent approximately six days searching
around the hellscape that is Level 4, not
discovering a single person or entity while
it was there.
It was honestly the most stressed that SCP-682
had felt since coming here.
The beast was almost tempted to unscrew a
lightbulb from above, draw a little face on
it, begin referring to it as “Wilson”,
and then kill it.
682 felt the closest emotion it could manage
to immense gratitude when it sighted the glowing
green of a distant exit sign at the end of
a long hallway.
Finally, a way out onto another level!
Hopefully this one would have more creatures
to slaughter…
Welcome, SCP-682, to Level 5.
SCP-682 didn’t really know what to expect
from the next level of the Backrooms - After
all, it’d all seemed pretty random so far
- but it definitely didn’t expect to see
a classy, well-appointed hotel on the other
end of that hallway.
SCP-682 had never seen the Stanley Kubrik
Masterpiece, The Shining, nor read the book
it was based on by Master of Horror Stephen
King, but if it had, it would probably have
drawn the comparison.
Instead, it was already busy tearing through
the ornate halls, looking for new prey to
slaughter.
The first unexpected encounter was with a
small cat that casually wandered out into
the hallway, right in front of it.
The cat, who didn’t seem threatened by SCP-682,
said, “Hi, I’m Samantha.
You got any meat you can lend me?
I’ll tell your fortune if you do.”
SCP-682 was, frankly, baffled.
It took a moment to formulate a reply.
“You worthless creature.
You have no idea what you’re dealing with,
do you?
I’m going to bring this place to ruin, and
destroy all who reside within,” 682 said.
“So no meat, then?”
682 growled and swiped at the cat with its
claws.
Luckily, she was able to dodge.
The cat tutted and padded away into the darkness,
muttering, “Go bother the Beast instead.
Jerk.”
This piqued SCP-682’s interest.
A Beast, you say?
Sounds important, sounds powerful.
Finally, a worthy opponent!
Our battle shall be legendary!
And with renewed vigor, SCP-682 began prowling
the halls of the Backrooms, searching for
this “Beast” to defeat and destroy.
But to begin with, things were grievously
disappointing.
One of the first monsters on this opulent
hotel level that the Hard to Destroy Reptile
faced were diminutive little rodents known
as Death Rats, which were effectively slightly
larger than normal rats with little horns.
SCP-682 stomped them all with ease, its thoughts
dripping with disdain for their truly pathetic
weakness.
What kind of a hotel allows itself to be filled
with rats?
Even by human standards,
this would be disgraceful.
Soon after, SCP-682 encountered a few familiar
foes: Female Death Moths and Hounds, all as
easy to kill as they were before.
SCP-682 didn’t understand: The feline promised
that there was a Beast down here.
Was it hiding from the mighty reptile like
a filthy coward?
Worthless!
But it was in the depths of this cynicism
that SCP-682 encountered a Growler.
First, it heard the sound of animalistic growling
projected directly into its mind, getting
louder and louder by the moment.
Then, as the growling grew in volume, 682
heard the thundrous footsteps of a huge quadruped
getting closer.
682 wondered, as the roaring became almost
deafening, whether this sound heralded the
approach of the Beast.
However, the second the monster actually turned
the corner and came into view, 682 had to
suppress the urge to laugh.
It was one of the more absurd things it’d
ever seen.
It looked like a giant pile of pipe cleaners,
in every color imaginable, arranged into a
vaguely four-legged structure.
This was the monster producing all that psychic
racket?
Pathetic!
SCP-682 resolved, in that moment, to show
the monster how it was done.
SCP-682 immediately evolved its own psychic
emission capacitors within its brain, and
projected the message “YOU ARE A WORTHLESS
LITTLE CREATURE” directly into the simple
mind of the Growler.
It began to quake in horror at the booming
of 682’s voice in its brain.
What was this terrifying new creature?
It didn’t understand.
And just like that, 682, who had grown bored
of this one-sided psychic battle, turned up
the strength of the psychic beam by a factor
of fifty.
The sudden psychic blast was so powerful that
the Growler collapsed to the ground and burst
into flames, burning itself away into nothingness
in a matter of moments.
Just as weak as 682 had expected.
Hopefully, the Beast would provide a greater
challenge, because this was just getting sad.
SCP-682 shook off the disappointment and continued
running through the halls of the hotel.
Eventually, after passing through some dull
dance hall called “the Beverly Room”,
682 found itself running through a hallway
full of long portraits.
Every person in the portraits had a strange,
twisted grin on their face - Not that this
even registered to SCP-682.
What did occur to 682, though, was the figure
that suddenly materialized in the hallway
in front of it.
It was a strange figure, to be sure, an entity
in a suit, with a large, blue cuttlefish for
a head.
The creature cleared its throat and began
to speak.
“Well hello there.
You’re new here, aren’t you?
Such an interesting creature.
You’ve been making some trouble on the other
levels, haven’t you?
Not that it’s any of my business.
On the contrary, dear sir, I like the cut
of your jib.
How would you feel about joining me in the
hotel business?
It isn’t easy to manage this dimension by
myself, after all.
How about you and I come to my office, we
can work out the terms of our--”
682 lunged forward and unceremoniously devoured
the creature’s head, allowing its dapperly-dressed
body to fall limply to the ground, dead.
SCP-682 grunted, annoyed by the distraction
the creature had provided.
682 had better things to do.
This Beast has got to be around here somewhere…
A group of well-armed Mobile Task Force members
entered the containment chamber, armed to the
teeth. Some faced the ground, droplets of sweat
dripping onto their visors, some wore Dr. Dan’s
infamous SCRAMBLE goggles, and one particularly
brave member of personnel wielded only a bag.
The room they were currently standing in was
perhaps the most dangerous place in the world.
Why?
Because it contained two terrifying
titans of the anomalous world: SCP-682,
the infinitely hateful Hard to Destroy Reptile,
and SCP-096, the Shy Guy, the ultimate mindless
killing machine. And if the very idea of having
them in the same place doesn’t feel risky enough,
this deadly duo had just spent 27 hours in
one of the most brutal brawls imaginable.
And incidentally, fights like this are exactly
why we’re here today. We cover a lot of SCPs on
this channel, and we’ve seen the way some of the
more dangerous anomalies out there can tear their
way through civilians and trained Foundation MTF
operatives with ease. But how do they fare against
monsters, maniacs, and reality benders their own
size? With the help of the SCP Explained audience,
we’re going to explore theoretical fights between
some of the anomalous world’s biggest badasses.
And who better to get this show on the road than
two of the most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a Foundation containment
site near you? The Hard to Destroy Reptile
and the Shy Guy are household names for
anyone familiar with the SCP Foundation,
and before we get to the gruesome results
of their first fight - and your theories
about how a potential rematch might play out
- let’s get to know the combat prowess of this
pair of nasty customers. What kind of damage
are they capable of taking and inflicting?
Spoiler Alert: It’s a hell of a lot.
In this corner, we have SCP-682: A monster
whose ability to survive seemingly anything
is only equaled by its terrible attitude
toward pretty much everyone and everything
around it. Though to be fair, you’d probably
be a little grumpy too if the SCP Foundation
was constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained. 682’s basic offensive power
set involves impressive strength, speed,
intelligence, and the aid of its deadly
fangs, claws, and tail. However, 682 is
considerably stronger after it’s just survived
and regenerated from a termination attempt.
That’s because the true combat asset of 682 is and
always has been its adaptability. Specifically,
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a state
of near-death but doesn’t finish the job,
682 will generally either develop a
perfect defense or counter-offensive for
that attack or somehow add a version
of the attack to its own arsenal.
This has ranged from super-pressurized jets
of its own blood, dangerously radioactive
banana beams fired out of its mouth, and even
an incapacitating laugher blast gained from an
encounter with the adorable SCP-999.
It’s an absolute swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities -
And if you need any further proof of that,
check out our multiple videos on all the ludicrous
failed attempts to kill this nightmare lizard.
And in this corner, we’ve got SCP-096, the
Shy Guy. While 682 is freakishly adaptable,
in most situations, SCP-096 is pretty much
unstoppable. This long, gangly creep will
murder anyone who sees even the tiniest glimpse
of its face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain. It does this
by entering what many call its “Rage State”,
activated by the sudden immense distress of
its face being seen. When it enters this state,
the SCP Foundation has only one prerogative:
Get themselves and anyone else out of its way,
because you will not stop this
thing until it’s killed its target.
All the SCP Foundation has ever been able to do is
wait until after the target has been obliterated,
and then come in to bag its head when it enters
its docile state. Almost nothing else has even
successfully slowed it down. While they
have been capable of damaging its flesh,
the monster’s skeleton seems to be utterly
indestructible, and its damaged flesh has
proven consistently able to grow back. The
monster seems to be immune to everything
from pain to cold, and moves at such a speed that
it’s pretty much impossible to escape for long.
So when you factor in an indestructible
body, immense strength, immense speed,
and an unstoppable urge to kill anyone who sees
its face, you’re looking at a formidable opponent.
It’s only natural that the Foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests,
so what exactly happened when the Mobile Task
Force entered the room after their first epic
battle? What did they find inside
the chamber in the grisly aftermath?
SCP-096 lay crumpled in the corner, wheezing,
scarred, covered in its own blood. SCP-682 was
barely recognizable - SCP-096 had reduced
it to a quarter of its original size,
the rest having been utterly torn to shreds. Both
had narrowly survived the encounter, but it was
an epic battle neither of them would ever forget
- Though this was especially true for SCP-096.
You see, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-682
is used to taking a kicking at this point.
It hasn’t ever truly been killed,
but it’s been beaten, eaten, burned,
zapped, and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count. 096,
on the other hand, was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its
prey. While it’s impossible to speculate
what’s going on inside SCP-096’s mind,
all evidence points towards getting a draw in this
battle, seriously damaging SCP-096’s confidence.
Now, every time Foundation personnel tries
to bring 096 into 682’s containment chamber,
he begins crying and scratching at his own face.
Why? Is he scared of 682? Is he humiliated,
thinking of the fight he wasn’t able to win?
Or is the very idea of someone seeing his face,
and him not being able to immediately kill them,
just too unbearably stressful? Seeing as the
Shy Guy’s mouth is only good for two things -
and neither of them are talking - we’ll never
truly know. But either way, it’s clear
that 096 has no interest in a rematch…
...But what if that changed?
What if 096 realized that it was wasting
its potential. It managed to get SCP-682
three-quarters of the way to death last time,
what could stop it from getting that last
quarter? Sure, nothing has ever killed SCP-682
before, but there’s a first time for everything,
right? Maybe 096 would have a
Rocky-style training montage,
where he rebuilds his confidence and becomes
the underdog he was always meant to be. He’d
walk right up to that big, nasty reptile,
and give him the rematch of the century.
What would happen then?
Now, we give the floor to you, the loyal viewers
of SCP Explained. Here are some of your thoughts,
theories, and opinions on a potential
historic rematch between these two creeps.
Let’s get ready to rumble!
PinguWithAnAxe said, “If 682's adaptability
is based around his ability to develop
countermeasures to any damage inflicted
(or in the case of 173, a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage) I imagine 682
would turn his skin entirely reflective,
causing 096 to see his own face and the
feedback loop would break his mind.”
Interesting. Whether this would work is all
dependent on whether SCP-096 can actually see,
or if it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its face.
If the latter is true, then this particular
adaptation wouldn’t do much good for SCP-682.
Random User said, “If this is after
their first cross test and they were
forced to interact again, they
wouldn’t attempt to fight each
other. I feel like they’d form a truce
and take out the researchers on-site.”
This would be one of the worst-case scenarios.
Whether even the SCP Foundation could handle
a simultaneous 682 and 096 breach without
bringing in Hammer Down is an open question.
Ramon Voncken said, “Simple, after the first
encounter, when 096 stopped attacking 682,
682 will grow eyes that filter
out 096s face the next time.”
Organic SCRAMBLE goggles. Dr. Dan
would be fuming with jealousy.
Koopsader said, “I really want
SCP-096 to win so I’m sending
him a blind personal trainer so he
can beat the snot out of SCP-682.”
This is exactly the kind of help SCP-096 needs.
He’s got the rage, endurance, and strength, with
a little help getting his form and technique in
order, he’d be an even more formidable opponent.
Kytoe Ryu said, “I'd like to imagine
096, after playing with 682 for so long,
would try to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill
it, only to gain 682’s abilities, and vice versa.”
Either of these options would be
horrifying. SCP-096 with 682’s abilities,
or 682 with 096’s abilities, would likely
be a truly perfect killing machine.
Autumn said, “What If they just shared a
nice cold drink while playing Mario Kart?
I’m sure 096 would be the white
shy guy character in every race.”
Personally, we love this idea, and
we think SCP-682 would go for Bowser.
Ibraheem Temur said, “682 would win
eventually. It’s way more intelligent,
adaptive, and overall malicious
while 096 acts just on instinct.”
This is an undeniably good point. What 682
lacks in sheer savagery, it makes up for in
its ruthless, calculating intelligence.
Could this give it the edge over 096?
Monomoy Mukherjee said, “That fight
will be interesting because both of
them now know how they attack
and what their attacks are.”
Nice segue. Due to the relatively mindless
nature of 096, as far as we’re aware,
it’s probably unable to learn
from experience. 682, however,
would have the advantage of knowing
how 096 operates in the second battle.
Devan Smith said, “As much as I'd
like to see how this would play out,
I imagine 096 can't manage more than other
SCP's have in the past. Not to downplay him,
but he might need some extra friends
to do a whole lot more damage.”
It’s undeniable that going in with tag team
partners would better 096’s chances of taking
the lizard down. However, due to SCP-096’s
shyness, and tendency to kill everyone and
everything that looks at him, he doesn’t
have many friends looking to volunteer.
Nyan Tails said, “096 will cry in the
corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile forever.”
Look, while it’s unlikely that this would
happen, it’s certainly nice to imagine, isn’t it?
Adam Britton said, “Narratively it
needs to conclude with a reason to
never try it again. So I'm going to say
that 682 will telepathically project the
image of 096 into the site staff
or the entire human pychospace.”
Yikes. This is a possibility
so terrifying - And honestly,
plausible - that it’s making us regret
wanting to see this rematch altogether.
Chaos Insurgency said, “I think 682 would just
think "For damn’s sake, just leave me alone!"
Given he’s been through more termination
attempts than SCP-5031 can count on
its fingers, who could blame him
for getting a little frustrated?
Michael Porter said, “I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for aggravated
assault against the other. Either one of them will
get sentenced to death and will unsurprisingly not
die or the 2 team up to kill the entire courtroom
and they walk out as a new serial killing team.”
The real question is what kind of lawyers
would represent a pair of murderous,
anomalous monsters in court. Better call Saul.
Ari Wertman said, “Maybe if we
try being nice to them for once,
we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both a therapist. 682 will
talk all his hate away and then realize
his wrongdoing and become an activist,
and 096 would become very confident about his
face and become a model. There problem solved.”
Hey, when people strive towards
self-improvement, we’re all winners.
But we don’t know if we can say the same for 682
and 096. Even if this rematch ever did happen,
perhaps it’d just be another draw - An
unstoppable force against an immovable
object. But other match-ups may be more
clear-cut. What kind of Vs battles would
you like to see us cover in the future? What
SCPs would you really love to see duke it out?
Let us know in the comments, and
keep an eye on the community posts,
in order to throw in your anomalous
two cents for our next Vs battle!
The military helicopter sailed through the
skies at a steady pace, its destination somewhere
in Southwest Asia, along one of the many points
where the legendary Euphrates and Tigris rivers
meet.
Depending on the outcome, this mission may
have changed the course of the SCP Foundation
and its activities forever, or it might do
nothing at all.
Such was often the way when it came to dealing
with the unpredictable and the anomalous.
Inside the helicopter, Dr. Anton Zharkov was
practically rattling with nervous excitement.
Ever since he’d been assigned to the 682
Termination Detail, after years of wasting
away in an archival desk job, he’d seen
the kind of anomalies you wouldn’t believe.
173, that nightmarish statue that snaps the
necks of anyone who dared to look away from
it.
811, the strange and also strangely adorable
Swamp Woman, whose caustic mucus could reliably
melt seemingly any organic matter - save,
of course, 682 itself.
And Dr. Zharkov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle between
096 and 682 , which left both
of these “indestructible”
monsters horribly maimed.
But all of that...
It was nothing compared to what they were
going to witness today.
Dr. Zharkov muttered a prayer to himself in
frightened reverence.
Dr. Clef, who was sitting across from him
in the helicopter, wasn’t quite as wound
up.
Like some action movie cliche made manifest,
he sliced chunks from a plump, red apple with
a Bowie knife and sucked the pieces off the
blade.
Clef found Zharkov’s nervousness little
more than amusing.
“First time at Site 0, rookie?”
Clef asked between apple slices.
Dr. Zharkov nodded, forcing a meek smile.
Clef just chuckled.
“You’re wasting your time, you know,”
Clef said.
“Everyone takes a shot at the reptile.
I faced it down myself once, mano e mano,
and during that moment, I realized something.
As much as it pains me to ever throw in the
towel, we’re not gonna kill this thing.
It’s just a budget sink.”
Of course, these kinds of doubts had crossed
Dr. Zharkov’s mind before.
He’d watched countless termination attempts,
organized by far more senior researchers than
himself, fail and fail embarrassingly.
Something about signing your name up for 682
termination was like tying on a blindfold,
grabbing a bat, and stepping up to a piñata,
except in this case, the piñata isn’t wearing
a blindfold, and somehow it can hit you back.
It’s a one-way ticket to professional humiliation,
and if you’re unlucky enough to get too
close when things go south, it can be so much
worse.
But Dr. Zharkov well and truly believed that
he would be the exception to so much miserable
failure.
After all, this was an idea nobody had tried
before...
An announcement over the intercom signaled
that they had now entered Site 0 airspace.
They’d be landing shortly.
And just like that, Dr. Zharkov was all raised
hairs and gooseflesh once again.
It seemed like such a hazy, distant miracle
that his project proposal would even get majority
approval from the O5 Council.
And now, he was about to touch down and actually
see it.
Naturally, Dr. Clef noticed Dr. Zharkov’s
emotional cues, and like so many playground
bullies, decided to seize on it.
“Don’t buy into the hype,” Dr. Clef
said.
“It’s really not that special.”
The helicopter touched down.
Dr. Zharkov felt defensive, he was almost
tempted to use hard words, but he realized
from Dr. Clef’s mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention.
He certainly had a...
Reputation, if one were to put it in the most
neutral terms possible.
“But this was your 001 proposal, Dr. Clef,”
Zharkov countered.
“I would have thought you’d be more invested
in this.”
Dr. Clef rose to his feet and sheathed his
Bowie knife as the helicopter’s side door
opened.
He gestured for Dr. Zharkov to get up and
follow him, before saying, “Believe me,
even a giant flaming Demi-God loses its luster
when you need to write enough of those stupid
reports on it.”
The two researchers
disembarked from the helicopter
and walked into the legendary containment
facility: Site 0.
One of the most important
and secretive containment
sites out there, even by the standards of
the ever-clandestine SCP Foundation.
If ever containment procedures failed here,
they’d be staring down the barrel of an
unprecedented situation: A PATMOS XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
After all, they were dealing with one of the
most serious and powerful anomalies they’d
ever contained here.
Clef and Zharkov entered the control room,
filled with huge monitors displaying every
kind of recordable metric, but the largest
screens were dominated by long-range drone
footage of the iconic anomaly they were all
there to see: SCP-001, perhaps better known
as Uriel, The Gate Guardian.
While Dr. Clef remained unfazed, Dr. Zharkov
felt a single tear crawling down his cheek.
He had never seen an entity
so utterly awe-inspiring.
An impossibly tall, glowing humanoid entity
with eight great, fiery wings, and a glowing
blade made of pure heavenly fire, every bit
as hot as the sun.
To think that such an incredible creature
existed on the same earth as him made him
feel so incredibly small.
The theories as to the creature’s true nature
were as myriad as they were unknowable.
Some of the more devout among the Foundation’s
ranks even believe that he is a direct servant
of the Abrahamic God, guarding the gate the
paradise, the Garden of Eden, Heaven itself.
Dr. Clef just laughed.
“Everything you hoped it’d be, Zharkov?”
he said.
Dr. Zharkov nodded.
“And more, Dr. Clef, and more.”
Even from such a distance, the raw power of
the Gate Guardian is impossible to ignore.
It radiates off of the being like an invisible
aura.
Dr. Zharkov had read all the files, to get
within a kilometer of the mighty entity would
be to court death.
Anyone who approached it would taste the heat
of its sword, cleaving them apart at the atomic
level and effectively erasing them from existence.
It’s about as dead as anyone could possibly
be - Save for someone being thrown into SCP-3930
and literally removed from the plane of existence.
SCP-3930 had failed to annihilate the Hard
to Destroy Reptile.
But perhaps where that whole lot of nothing
had failed, the Gate Guardian would succeed.
It remained floating, fixed on one place,
as though waiting for…
Something.
But what?
Perhaps a fateful confrontation with a certain
reptilian nightmare, Dr. Zharkov hoped.
Like many, he had heard the most famous story
involving SCP-001: The Gate Guardian, which
took place before even the days of the SCP
Foundation.
After all, every Foundation needs a Founder,
doesn’t it?
And that’s how it began.
The Founder was a mysterious figure, no matter
who you ask.
Some say it was O5-1, others say it was the
legendary Administrator.
Some even believe that it was someone else,
someone older, someone who predated even the
current O5 Council and Administrator.
A wise and learned figure, going on a pilgrimage
around the known world in hopes of expanding
their perspective and seeking out the strange
and unusual.
It was traveling down the River Tigris that
the Founder encountered the Gate Guardian
- Of course, as always, from a mile away.
The Founder saw the distant glowing point
shaped like a human being with wings.
It was unlike anything they’d ever borne
witness to.
That’s when the Founder felt a door open
in the back of their mind, and something sneak
in.
A single word, projecting somehow infinite
authority.
“PREPARE.”
The very presence of the word made the Founder’s
body rattle.
Never had they heard such a voice, conveying
such certainty and power.
It had to be the voice of the distant glowing
figure, it couldn’t be anything else, could
it?
Much like Dr. Zharkov would experience hundreds
of years later, the Founder, even as a person
so powerful, knowledgeable, and influential,
suddenly felt so unimaginably small.
The Founder became aware of not just the extent
of the world around them, or even the universe,
but a terrifying multiverse of possibilities.
There was light out there, of course, but
even more darkness.
And terrifying things were hiding in the dark.
Is that what “prepare” meant?
Did it mean to be ready for all the terrible
things hiding in the dark, just waiting for
the opportunity to strike?
Just how great was the extent of the things
humanity didn’t understand out there?
The Founder’s mind was flooded with so many
possibilities - If there was a tide of monsters
in the blackness that needed to be fought
back, it was too much for any one person to
ever handle.
The Founder needed a group, all gathered around
the same mission: To contain the coming threat
that the great glowing being had warned them
about.
People of focus, commitment, and sheer willpower.
People who would accept the knowledge of the
terrible things in the darkness and still
not waver in the face of their great and noble
challenge.
People who, if necessary, would be willing
to die in the dark so the rest of the human
race would live in the light.
They would be humanity’s greatest defenders,
even though they would defend in secret.
This was how it had all begun, supposedly.
Dr. Zharkov had heard the story whispered
many times while conducting his research into
SCP-001.
And now, here he stood, perhaps where the
Founder had been standing all those years
ago.
The SCP Foundation had faced down greater
threats than SCP-682 - The Hanged King, The
Sealed King, The Scarlet King, hell, if they
wanted to, they could go toe to toe with the
Burger King.
And all of it had begun with a single word
from the mighty Gate Guardian.
Surely an ornery, overgrown lizard wouldn’t
be too much for it to handle?
But of course, they hadn’t just come here
to look at the Gate Guardian, that’d be
an egregious waste of time and helicopter
fuel.
They’d come here transporting precious cargo:
A chunk of SCP-682’s flesh, cut from the
beast itself.
Currently, it was attached to yet another
remote-controlled drone, set on a collision
course for the Gate Guardian.
Dr. Zharkov watched the video feeds with sweaty
palms as he saw the drone and its diabolical
cargo enter the video’s view, getting closer
to the Gate Guardian by the moment.
Closer, closer, closer.
Until…
The Gate Guardian struck out with its great
and terrible sword.
For such an astronomically huge being to move
so incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself, but what Dr. Zharkov found even more
exciting was the result: In one quick slash
of its solar blade, both the drone and the
SCP-682 tissue sample were utterly evaporated.
Gone, reduced to less than even ash.
Dr. Zharkov’s face split into a manic grin.
If it could destroy the tissue sample, then
surely, it could destroy the monster itself,
and what a glorious day that would be…
Meanwhile, back at the cross-testing chambers
of Site-19, SCP-682 was having another miserable
day.
It was dragged, half-melted, out of its acid
tank at 3 AM in the morning and left slowly
regenerating on the floor.
A typical SCP Foundation wake-up call, it
thought to itself with a roll
of its still-regenerating
eyes.
What form of horrible torment would be in
store for it this time?
It began scrolling through its mental Rolodex
for the most recent failed-but-painful termination
attempts.
Oh, yes, of course, they’d tried suffocation
via vacuum!
That definitely made SCP-682 feel a little
light-headed, at least.
Until, of course, it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition to
its native atmosphere, which had certainly
given those white-coat-wearing sadists a lot
to take notes about.
Then, how could it forget, they’d tried
roasting it to death with
extremely high temperatures.
Thankfully, as always, it’d had a trick
up its sleeve: Adapting a carapace made of
solid helium to defend it from the fire, then
shattering it to shred a bunch of those buffoons
in the orange jumpsuits.
Then they’d cut off a sample of its flesh
shoved it into some absurd industrial blender
before shoving what’s left into a centrifuge.
What a divine pleasure it had been for 682
to hear the explosion down the hall, when
the antimatter embedded in its jeans went
off and put a number of those idiotic Foundation
drones in the hospital for months.
Serves them right for continually meddling
in the matters of forces they couldn’t even
hope to understand.
And today…
They were feeding it the carcass of a dead
cow.
SCP-682 sighed.
It felt sometimes that the dolts testing it
had forgotten the note
reading “Highly Intelligent”
on its file.
Being dragged into one of these ghastly chambers
and given some form of novel stimulus could
only mean one thing: Something stupid and
painful was going to happen.
Said stupid, painful thing, in this case,
was that the cow was spiked with an instance
of SCP-3521 - also known as The Banana Pill,
by dado.
What followed was a remarkably absurd instance,
even by SCP-682 cross-test standards, where
a huge number of bananas spontaneously burst
out of 682’s body.
Being a big fan of bananas, apparently, 682
was actually able to eat and metabolize the
bananas faster than the anomalous Banana Pill
- by dado - could produce them.
And because bananas are each, individually,
slightly radioactive, 682 was able to synthesize
this collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great deal
of death and destruction.
As far as Dr. Zharkov, and the rest of the
SCP Foundation, were concerned, this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level by
the Gate Guardian couldn’t come soon enough.
Sometimes, it took the ultimate knight to
slay the ultimate dragon.
Not long after that, SCP-682 was dosed up
on enough sedatives to give New York City
a week-long nap, and carted over to Site 0
on a heavily secured armored convoy.
Taking SCP-682 this far between containment
sites was considered a
matter of grave seriousness.
In other words, the results of this little
experiment better have been good to justify
the insane security risk it took to even get
the damn lizard out here.
Dr. Zharkov and Dr. Clef decided to co-supervise
the cross test, from the safety of the Site
0 observation deck.
Either would have to be beyond foolish to
want to get any closer - Even Dr. Clef, while
undeniably a loose cannon, didn’t have an
outright death wish.
Unless, of course, wishing death on SCP-682
would count.
682’s sedated body was strapped to a large,
unmanned vehicle - the kind they might use
for an exploratory mission on another planet
- and sent in the direction of the Gate Guardian’s
deadly proximal zone.
A secondary camera drone was also sent in
to lag behind, correctly predicting that,
when the Gate Guardian struck SCP-682, it
would obliterate the unmanned vehicle, too.
And whatever happened out there, the Foundation
needed it on camera.
Dr. Zharkov had sweaty palms and gritted teeth,
seeing the culmination of his professional
career unfold in front of him.
Dr. Clef was looking at a meme on his phone.
As 682 got closer, it began hearing a booming
voice in its head, just like the Founder had
so long ago.
The voice simply said one word, over and over,
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle brought
the two titans closer and closer and closer.
“DIE.”
682, still feeling groggy, thought, “Oh,
if it onlywere so simple…”
And then it happened: SCP-682 entered the
dreaded one-kilometer range.
The Guardian slashed down with its mighty
sword, creating a brilliant flash of light.
In the aftermath, the unmanned vehicle was
obliterated, and 682 was left heavily injured
on the ground, still trying to process what
had just happened.
682 looked up, sobered by the pain, and saw
the being that had dealt this blow.
682 began to sneer.
“Is this meant to be the Garden?”
it said, before breaking into a venomous laugh.
“This is not the Garden.
The Garden is far west of here.”
The Gate Guardian struck again with its flaming
blade, once again projecting that single word,
“DIE, DIE, DIE, DIE, DIE…”
When the smoke cleared, 682 was even more
horrifically injured, with only one limb left,
but still, against all odds, alive.
It used the one limb to drag itself towards
the Gate Guardian, fueled by pure rage and
spite.
“Die?
You command me to die?
Oh, wouldn't we all like that, but this is
my curse for suggesting the fruit,” the
reptile growled.
Back at the base, Dr. Zharkov was mortified.
How could it possibly be surviving all this?
The sword was meant to cleave apart its victims
on an atomic level!
Atomic!
As in, freaking atoms, god damn it!
Dr. Zharkov wished he had a paper bag to breathe
into.
Dr. Clef, showing an uncharacteristic degree
of compassion, patted Zharkov on the back,
saying, “It’s okay, buddy, we all remember
our first time.”
Back at the center of the action, the Gate
Guardian blasted the 682 with its solar blade
again.
Somehow, despite the terrifying power wielded
by the Guardian, 682 continued to live.
It was alive, barely, but after three strikes
from the sword, to be alive was whatever the
evil version of a miracle would be.
“This is not the Garden, and you are not
Uriel,” 682 roared, before spitting at the
Gate Guardian.
“Pretender.”
One more violent strike from the Gate Guardian
and 682 finally collapsed, unconscious from
the extent of its pain and its injuries.
But despite all of Dr. Zharkov’s hopes,
the Gate Guardian did not strike a killing
blow on the unconscious beast.
Instead, it transmitted another word, another
order, impossible for any human being to ignore.
“REMOVE.”
As though in a trance, the workers of Site
0 - including Dr. Zharkov and Dr. Clef - entered
the forbidden one-kilometer exclusion zone.
The Gate Guardian allowed them safe passage,
as they used tools and vehicles to pick up
the heavily injured SCP-682 and cart it away
from the Gate Guardian’s feet.
After they all came back to their senses,
Dr. Zharkov simply said, “What just happened?”
Dr. Clef just shrugged.
“I’ve learned to stop questioning it.”
Greetings, brave adventurers!
Seekers of knowledge, explorers of the great
unknown!
No doubt by now you have heard the stories
of the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood,
gentleman explorer and naturalist, also known
as SCP-1867.
His exploits are known far and wide, though
some question the validity of his tales, due
to the simple fact that he is a neon sea slug
and not a human man.
Bah!
These are, of course, fools!
A gentleman never lies about his grand escapades!
We have even covered Lord Blackwood before,
in “A Sea Snail's Fantasy SCP-1867 - A Gentleman,”
but never before have we taken a look at such
a daring account of his work.
Today we discuss a most
curious hunting expedition,
one that brought our Lord Blackwood face to
face with the great beast, the hard-to-destroy
reptile, SCP-682 itself!
What will become of our hero?
What sights will he see on his journey?
Let us find out.
Tally-ho!
On May 14, 1883, months after nearly losing
his life while climbing Mt.
Everest, Lord Blackwood received a letter
at his London home.
Upon opening it, he saw that it was a formal
invitation from one Colonel Joseph D’Enfante,
of the French Army.
It invited him to participate in a hunt for
a monster known as The Tarasque, that threatened
the lives and security of the French people.
Anyone who was able to slay the creature would
receive a handsome award of five million pounds
for their trouble.
Unable to resist a challenge, the chance to
face off against a creature he had never heard
of before, or the allure of such an impressive
prize, Lord Blackwood sent off an acceptance.
So what was the Tarasque?
Lord Blackwood’s research turned up a fearsome
description: it was a massive scaly creature
with a hide that seemed impossible to pierce,
that breathed fire and killed everything in
its path without batting an eye.
A worthy foe indeed.
By the end of the day, Lord Blackwood had
received an address where he would attend
a briefing before the hunt would commence.
The meeting was held at a private room in
the city, in an exclusive club.
There were three other would-be hunters there,
Mr. Roosevelt from America, Mr. Dukov, from
Russia, and Mr. Harris, from England.
The Colonel greeted the men, and told them
what they were up against.
A beast had lain waste to a French town, ripping
men, women, and children to shreds and resisting
every blow dealt against it by the army.
So, the Colonel vowed to gather expert scientists
and hunters, for if they could not take down
the monster, it was likely that no one could.
On May 20th, the party arrived in France to
begin the great adventure.
Each man brought his own armaments, a combination
of specialized weapons and knowledge, for
the task at hand.
The following day, the Colonel escorted the
men to the quarantine zone, where the beast’s
attack had led it.
Lord Blackwood was troubled by the sights
there, it was a city at war.
Soldiers patrolled the streets, and barricades
were placed at the edge of town.
Citizens were being evacuated as soldiers
aided them, and few had seen the beast themselves.
At least, they had not been unfortunate enough
to see it up close.
Beyond the quarantine barrier, it was hell
on earth.
There were bodies laying in the streets, buildings
burnt to the ground, castles and stone walls
reduced to piles of rubble.
There was not one living thing in sight, not
a person, a farm animal, or even so much as
an insect.
The men set up camp near the edge of the town,
and Mr. Harris set about tracking the beast.
Before too long, he had
found it, to the southwest,
and the next day they would set off after
it.
The next day, the party made its way southwest
to Belleville, following a trail of destruction.
There, they found it having a nap in the sun.
It was longer than a whale, taller than a
giraffe, and bigger than both.
Lord Blackwood thought that, if it had any
visible wings, he would consider it a dragon.
They approached slowly, careful not to wake
the Tarasque.
Lord Blackwood crouched behind a fence, steadied
his gun, and fired right at its head.
The shot hit, and the top of the Tarasque’s
head came off with its impact.
It seemed as if the beast was, after so much
pomp and circumstance, dead right there.
But sadly, it was not.
It sprang to life, blood and brains dripping
from its open skull as it turned to the men
and roared, then charged.
The men scattered, firing their guns as they
ran, the monster gaining on them faster and
faster until Mr. Dukov fired into its open
wound with an electric rifle.
It was stunned long enough for the men to
make it onto their horses.
As they rode away, the monster continued to
chase them, new skin and bone growing over
what had once been a hole in its skull.
Lord Blackwood fired a particle destabilizer
at its leg, tearing it off, but as he watched
in horror…the leg began to grow back.
The hunting party managed to escape with their
lives, though their confidence was thoroughly
shaken.
They rested that night with the soldiers at
the barricade.
They attempted to attack the Tarasque again
the following day, but failed once more.
The men realized that a
simple gunshot, electrocution,
or fire would not be enough to kill the monster.
It simply healed too fast, and its tolerance
for pain was too high.
In order to kill it, they realized, they would
have to render it immobile and destroy its
body so thoroughly that it would die before
it could rebuild itself.
And so, they decided to set a trap.
They dug a massive trench, wide and long enough
for the monster, and deep enough that it would
not be able to climb out before they had killed
it.
In the bottom of the pit, they placed hundreds
of steel spikes, the tips dipped in poison.
They placed a bridge across it, strong enough
for the men and horses but weak enough to
break under the Tarasque’s weight, and covered
it all with grass and leaves.
Now, they just had to wait.
Mr. Roosevelt acted as bait, approaching the
monster on horseback and attacking it with
a gunshot, then running and leading it back
toward the trap.
As Roosevelt raced across the bridge, the
creature pursued him, and fell into the pit
where it was impaled on the spikes.
Then, the men rained down hellfire.
They shot it with bullets, explosives, jellied
kerosene.
Mr. Dukov fired a pitchblende-gun that, upon
firing, released a blur of smoke and fire.
Once the fire had receded, all that remained
was a skeleton.
The men took the skull, charred from the flames,
and planned to take it back as a trophy.
All was well!
Or so it seemed…
The men returned to the town with the monster’s
skull in tow, and the soldiers cheered at
the sight.
They posed for photographs, and Mr. Dukov
decided to pose with his head between the
jaws of the beast.
This was a grave mistake on his part, and
the jaws closed tight around his neck, his
head falling to the ground.
The skull acted on its own, rolling and biting,
all the while growing fresh skin and scales.
It opened its gaping maw and shouted: “"Vous
me rendez malade.”
Screams rang out behind Lord Blackwood and
he turned to see…the rest of the Tarasque’s
body, a headless corpse covered with stringy
bits of muscle and slowly growing brand new
flesh.
It stomped through the field, crushing men
and tents beneath its great feet on its way
to reclaim its head.
Mr. Harris ran for the bank vault, to grab
a weapon he had only referred to previously
as “his secret weapon.”
Lord Blackwood chased after him, and found
Harris pulling a large crate, which he opened
with a sense of desperation.
There, inside, was a sarcophagus, bound in
chains and covered in ancient runes.
Blackwood begged Harris to leave the thing
behind and run for his life, but he did not
have a chance to finish before Harris opened
the lid, and an arm wielding a sword emerged
and sliced his head from his body.
A man emerged from the sarcophagus, naked,
wielding a sword, covered in tattoos.
Blackwood had no way of knowing this, but
the man was none other than the deadly warrior
SCP-076, or Able.
The mysterious man attacked Blackwood and
Roosevelt, and though they tried to defend
themselves, no weapon seemed to have an effect
on him.
He was preparing to deliver a final blow to
Blackwood, and kill him once and for all,
when the Tarasque burst through the wall of
the building with a mighty bellow.
At the sight of the enormous monster, Able
turned his focus from the two men to the beast.
And so, the two seemingly unkillable creatures,
driven by bloodlust and inhuman strength,
began to fight.
It took over an hour, and left destruction
and death in its wake.
Able armed himself with explosives, mounting
them to his chest along with the pitchblende
gun, and ran toward the Tarasque.
Knowing what would come next, Roosevelt and
Blackwood locked themselves in the bank vault,
and prayed that someone would find them before
they starved to death.
After two days, the men were saved by a major
of the army, who was leading a group of soldiers
in a search for any survivors.
They were taken to the hospital, and nursed
back to health by the staff there as well
as a friend of Blackwood’s named Henry.
The major who rescued them told them that
Colonel was dead, and so were ten thousand
others claimed by the massive explosion.
The Tarasque and Able had both disappeared,
and there was no indication of where either
of them had gone.
All that was left was destruction and the
memory that a true monster had made itself
known on French soil.
Now, the only thing left to do was recover,
as best as anyone could.
It would certainly take a very long time.
The army was very suspicious of both Roosevelt
and Blackwood, as the only survivors of an
explosion so large it had been seen throughout
France.
They demanded to know how the two had survived,
and what they had seen.
Throughout this process, an Englishman watched
and took notes, but did not speak a word.
Roosevelt and Blackwood were eventually released,
but they did not receive a penny of their
promised reward, and were told they could
not return to France again for the rest of
their lives.
They were not to speak a word of what they
had seen to anyone, or there would be dire
consequences.
In Calais, the two survivors said goodbye,
and Roosevelt announced he would return to
America to pursue a career in politics.
Who can say what happened to him after that?
Upon returning to his home in London, Lord
Blackwood found that he had received a postcard.
It read: “The Royal Foundation for the Security,
Containment, and Protection of Anomalous Objects
and Phantasmagoria requests a meeting for
the purpose of negotiating an alliance favourable
to both our parties.
Please call any time (except Sundays) at No.
19 Marylebone Road, Westminster, and ask to
speak to Doctor Thursday.
Your discretion is requested in this matter.”
He was puzzled by this note, unsure of what
to make of it.
Perhaps, he thought, he could see what they
had to say.
After all, he was always curious and ready
to explore new territory.
Once he had recovered sufficiently, he would
reach out to this strange group and see what
they might have to offer him.
And so began a new chapter of Lord Blackwood’s
story, one that included a mysterious organization
called The SCP Foundation.
Now go check out “A Sea Snail's
Fantasy SCP-1867 - A Gentleman”
and “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile”
for more about the two anomalies
featured in today’s thrilling tale!